Guten Morgen Linus.
Guten Morgen Tim.
Was ist denn das für ein Ton?
Das muss der Cyber sein.
Bis platt war.
Das gedacht, dass der Cyber so schnell über einen kommt.
Ja, über uns alle.
Über uns alle, genau. Ja, hier ist Lokbuch Netzpolitik, Ausgabe eins, eins, vier,
Wir hatten eine kleine Pause, das war äh technisch und nachrichtentechnisch äh bedingt. Es gab nicht so viel und wir waren zu faul und
verhindert und überhaupt und schön zu sehen, wie ihr alle immer total durchdreht, wenn mal äh eine Woche keinen äh Logbuch Netzpolitik kommt, auch absolut äh nachvollziehbar. Ähm können euch auch gleich warnen, dass wir so,
Grade bei der Terminplanung für das nächste halbe Jahr gesehen haben, da kommen noch ein paar ruppige Zeiten auf uns zu, aber äh wir versuchen natürlich immer ähm hier was in Bewegung zu halten.
Natürlich an dieser Stelle Arne Bense danken.
Genau, Arne Benzel hat nämlich äh schön nach der letzten Sendung unseren kleinen, was war's? Tipp, Aufruf, ich weiß gar nicht, wir haben's so fallen lassen irgendwie, ne?
Nochmal den Wunsch vernachdrücklich und dann hat's nicht lange gedauert äh.
Schon war ärgere ich mich so ein bisschen, dass wir die Sendung nicht Cyber Cyber genannt haben.
Können wir doch den diese Sendung nennen wir jetzt Cyber Cyber und dann haben wir Cyber und Cyber Cyber.
Anne, äh Anne kriegt natürlich auch noch den den.
Den großen Gefallen. Anne kriegt auch noch den großen Gefallen, dass wir darauf hinweisen, wohlwollend darauf hinweisen, dass der Chaos-Treff Osnabrück sich gerade in Gründung befindet und sich über Zuwachs freut.
Organisiert ist sozusagen.
Genau. Und sein sein äh Soundcloud äh Profil, wo es diesen Song und viele weitere gibt. Äh ist natürlich auch bei uns in den Shownotes verlinkt. Mhm. Und ja, ich äh war äh.
Wir machen auch noch einen Flatterbutton dazu.
Der müsste auch irgendwie da bei SongCloud sein, aber da achten wir natürlich auch drauf, dass.
Nee, der wird dann bei uns sein.
Genau, jetzt auch bei uns. Sowas ist.
Jetzt auch bei uns.
Sowas ist vor allem, ich finde das sehr, sehr cool, wenn solche Sachen passieren und gefühlt.
Gefühlt äh haben wir so was äh früher öfter gehabt. Ähm also es hat zum, also bei äh also wir als jene ähm haben wir als jene Netzgemeinde.
Ach so, wir wir die Netzgemeinden.
Da war irgendwie, das war häufig, das ist nicht ähm schlecht, wenn wenn öfter öfter witzige Dinge geschehen, wie zum Beispiel,
Steffen Seibert, Steffen Seibert kennen, auch geboren in den Kommentaren von Lokbuch Netzpolitik.
Das ist sozusagen der der Regierungssprecher der digitalen Regierung sozusagen.
Ja, nee, der, der hat äh natürlich auch eine.
Digitalisierten.
Also unter äh Steffen Seibert äh twittert der äh,
Cyber-Sprecher der Cyber-Regierung und Chef des Bundes Cyberamtes, Abteilung Satire, ja, also wer jeder weiß, Steffen Seibert, der ähm,
Der Regierungssprecher hier als Steffen Seibert unterwegs und.
Findet hier sozusagen sein digitales Äquivalent.
Ja und der twittert die ganze Zeit ähm Ausschnitte, hauptsächlich aus der digitalen Agenda, Sätze aus der digitalen Agenda und anderen äh Cyberveröffentlichungen der Cyber Republik.
Du meinst, das sind alles Originalzitate aus der Agenda?
Ausschließlich äh also es gibt, glaube ich, eine.
Wie auch jetzt eben in dem Song. Genau. Das war echt schon gut, dass man da eigentlich überhaupt gar nichts mehr hinzuerfinden muss und das wirkt schon absurd.
Die fortschreitende Digitalisierung schafft neue Tätigkeitsfelder und bietet Chancen für Beschäftigung.
Wir helfen den Menschen, ihr Bewusstsein für und ihre Kenntnisse über die Sicherheit im Netz zu stärken.
Die wachsende Bedeutung des Internets im Alltag führt dazu, dass sich das bürgerschaftliche Engagement immer mehr ins Netz verlagert.
Digitale Infrastrukturen als Vertrauensraum stärken.
Die Verwaltung soll über verschiedene Wege sicher und einfach erreichbar sein. Wir führen D-Mail flächendeckend ein.
Also auch schon ein paar Drohungen enthalten, ja, das äh da ist das äh bei Twitter noch als Satira Account durchgeht, ist bemerkenswert.
Wir beabsichtigen die Durchführung eines Modellprojektes freiwilliges soziales Jahr digital.
Ja, sehr.
War sonst noch irgendwas?
Ja, also äh.
Da war doch eine Demo.
Da war eine Demo.
Ja, wir waren nicht da. Wir waren nicht da. Du warst verhindert.
Ich war im Ausland. Ich habe eine gute Ausrede. Was ist deine?
Äh ich habe also.
Ich weiß gar nicht, ob ich da noch hingegangen wäre, wäre es mir an dem Tag nicht auch noch komplett entfallen. Also ich hatte es dann auch einfach überhaupt nicht äh die Bohne äh auf äh auf dem Zeiger, aber ich.
War auch schon so
wie soll ich sagen, an excited, also mir ich mir missfällt ein wenig, äh mir missfallen generell so Veranstaltungen, die einfach den Eindruck machen, dass sie einfach nur noch so einem bestimmten Ritus äh erfüllen
ja äh womit ich auch nicht sagen will, dass dass man das grundsätzlich nicht machen kann, das ist schon irgendwie okay, aber.
Erstmal so eine Demonstration kann irgendwie zwei Effekte haben. Ja, im Idealfall.
Wirkt sie auf die gesamte Gesellschaft und alle sind irgendwie komplett entsetzt und beeindruckt, wie viele Leute da jetzt auf einmal zusammenkommen und sich irgendwie unter so einem Themenmantel äh äh hervor,
tun und alle sind total schockiert und alle Gesetze werden sofort geändert so, ne? Das ist sozusagen das das ist das eine Ideal, was man.
Dass wir immer wieder sehen.
Ja, na okay. Ich meine, das war jetzt, ich rede ja auch von einem Ideal, dass man da selten hinkommt. Aber das gab's ja auch schon. Also ist ja auch, ist ja auch nicht so, dass jetzt Demonstrationen generell wirkungslos sind, aber in den allermeisten Fällen habe ich so den Eindruck,
Effekt generell gegenüber solchen Demonstrationen. Ja, also sie können eigentlich nur wirken, wenn sie auf eine überraschende Art und Weise groß sind.
Oder äh auf eine überraschende Art und Weise besetzt sind. Ähm
Ja und die zweite Wirkung ist halt diese Innenwirkung, ja, um einfach eine bestimmte Szene zusammenzuschweißen, so mit hier, du bist nicht allein, andere Leute äh vertreten das selber. Wir kämpfen für die gemeinsamen Ziele und so weiter. Das ist im Wesentlichen so die beiden Wirkungsfelder, die ich sehe für Demonstrationen,
Was Letzeres betrifft.
Hatte ich bei der Freiheit Angst eh schon immer so ein bisschen das Gefühl, dass es da nicht unbedingt hier zu so sehr viel Konsens äh gibt, wohin die Reise geht, das kann man auch anders sehen,
Aber ich finde halt auch einfach die Energie, die ja äh reingesteckt werden muss in eine Veranstaltung zu machen in äh und dann im Hinblick auf ihre Außenwirkung, also auf letzten Endes, was erreicht man damit tatsächlich, ja, unabhängig von diesem,
nach innen gerichteten äh Appell ist halt einfach zu vorhersehbar, ja. Findet statt,
Ja, im September, dann fahren sie alle wieder nach Berlin. Da macht man schon so seine Partys und seinen sonstigen Treffen drumherum. Passt ja und dann laufen wir ein bisschen durch Mitte und zeigen den Touristen unsere Schilder. Ja, ansonsten ist da halt niemand.
Ist jetzt eine etwas überspitzte Sicht vielleicht da drauf. Also das ist das, das ist ein bisschen mein Gefühl gewesen.
Und ich würde mir sehr viel mehr wünschen, dass ein bestimmtes Demonstrationspotential sehr viel mehr in überraschende Aktionen äh umgesetzt hat. Da fehlt mir einfach so ein bisschen der Guerilla äh Aspekt.
Trotzdem haben wir jetzt dieses Problem im Prinzip an der Backe, dass diese Demonstrationen ja auch in einer gewissen Form ja stattfinden muss,
Er wartet wird, ja, ähm das ist eine der Demonstrationen, die, wann war dieser Höhepunkt? Ähm.
Also die größte Freiheit statt Angst, die ja dann irgendwie in äh Tagesschauen, was nicht alles war, als es dann äh um ich weiß nicht genau, in welchem Jahr das war.
Ehemann zweitausendsechs zweitausendacht oder so.
Post Ursel sozusagen.
Ja, genau. Da war das natürlich, da war diese ähm Freiheit statt Angst, das war ja irgendwie eine der eine der Deutschen Großdemonstrationen des Jahres,
im Prinzip vom von der von der Presseaufmerksamkeit her. Und es ist natürlich ein ein Drama, dass sie das in im letzten Jahr und in diesem Jahr nicht geworden ist, weil diesen, wann war das jetzt, Samstag oder Sonntag, den Nachmittag am Wochenende,
Den kann man schon mal aufbringen, ja? Vor allem, wenn sich da drum Randprogramm äh äh ähm.
Wird es.
Weitere Attraktionen gibt.
Noch weitere Attraktionen gibt, ja? Wenn man, wenn das so quasi
FSA-Wochenende, ja, wo dann alle sagen, wir sind in Berlin und wir äh da machen wir bei der Gelegenheit noch irgendwie einen Stammtisch in der Seabays und äh
eine Hecke von im in äh im im CCB oder weiß der Geier, ja, aber genau die Dinge passieren eben auch nicht, ja? Das heißt, diese,
Dieser Klassentreffen Charakter auch zu gegenseitigen Bestärkungen. Das mag jetzt sein, dass du sagst, der äh der nutzt sich ab und der ist nicht der Weisheit letzter Schluss. Das sehe ich auch so. Ähm und ähm ich bin ja auch selber nicht da gewesen. Aber es wäre natürlich,
trotz allem ein wünschenswerter Effekt,
dass so eine Demonstration mehr als äh sechseinhalbtausend äh berichtete Besucher hat, weil sie eben auch schon mal sehr weit da drüber war. Ähm.
Und das ist äh dann doch insgesamt äh beklagenswert. Ich sage nicht, dass es keine anderen Aktionen geben soll. Ich sage nicht, dass diese Freiheit Angst eine besonders ähm originelle oder tolle Veranstaltung ist,
aber es ist eben auch ähm eine Marke, die sich da jetzt gerade selber verbrät,
und ähm das äh,
letztendlich auch unser politisches Anliegen drunter, wenn man eben sieht, wenn jemand in der CDU sieht, na ja.
Kriege ja eh nichts auf die.
Die kriegen ja noch nicht mal irgendwie ein paar Mann auf der Straße, was soll ich mich mit denen überhaupt auseinandersetzen? Ja. Ähm insofern sehe ich da.
Da jetzt einfach mal die Kraft haben zu sagen OK so das ja war irgendwie durch jetzt,
Denken wir uns das vielleicht mal was Neues aus, was eben jetzt nicht einfach nur dieser normale äh traditionelle Schützenfestzug da durch die Straßen ist, weil das finde ich ist auch irgendwie so ein bisschen, ehrlich gesagt, also Protest geht auch kreativer
Haben wir ja gerade gehört. Also man kann ja,
das vielleicht auch mal ganz anders aufstellen und sich einfach über neue Protestformen auch mal äh Gedanken machen, also nicht, dass es das nicht im Einzelnen auch äh gibt, aber mit der Energie und dem Geld letzten Endes auch, was so eine Veranstaltung gesteckt,
könnte man sicherlich noch ein paar putzigere äh Sachen machen.
Absolut richtig. Äh trotzdem äh also ich bin, ich bedaure es trotzdem, dass dass diese Veranstaltung eben offenbar wenig Anklang. Findet gefunden.
Ja ist so, also muss man halt, muss man einfach zur Kenntnis nehmen, dass es jetzt so ist, das kann man natürlich bedauern und beklagen, aber von Bedauern und Beklagen kommen wir nicht weiter.
Nee, es hat natürlich also es gibt ja, das haben wir, glaube ich, im letzten Jahr, ja, schon bei unserem Rückblick ein bisschen betrachtet damals, war, glaube ich, Anne Roth hier zu Gast. Ähm.
Es gab natürlich dann auch intern in diesem Organisationsbündnis gab's dann irgendwelche
Überwerfungen oder Diskussionen oder Debatten, die dann dazu geführt haben, dass äh bestimmte Organisationen sich eben jetzt nicht besonders groß eingebracht haben, andere Organisationen sich besonders groß eingebracht haben. Das ist natürlich auch scheiße. Wenn du eine Bewegung überhaupt erst mal an diesem Punkt hast, dass es sowas überhaupt gibt, ja?
Dass Gruppen sagen hä, wir finden irgendwie keinen bei uns, der äh sich mit dieser Sache auseinandersetzen möchte und das war bedauerlich, aber wir können jetzt auch keinen zwingen und ähm
Ja, ja, wir unterzeichnen den Demoaufruf mit, aber macht mal unser Logo jetzt nicht allzu groß. Äh wir wollen halt äh wir wollen die Schlagzeile vermeiden, dass wir
uns irgendwie unsolidarisch von diesem Ding
Brennen, ja, ähm aber gleichzeitig ähm wollen wir da selber keinerlei Ressourcen äh reinstecken aus äh verschiedenen Erwägungen.
Hast du irgendwas darüber gehört, wie groß du das Luni äh Potenzial war auf der Veranstaltung? Ich meine, das ist ja auch früher immer schon so
diese ganzen Flachköpfe da von Info war und äh sonstigen Verschwörungsabteilungen dazu gestoßen. Jetzt gibt's ja auch diese ganze Montags äh.
Der wohl auch irgendwie ja ich habe nicht ich weiß, dass die da dass die dafür geworben haben, aber.
Ja, das halte ich ja, das halte ich nämlich auch für absolut problematisch. Ja, weil mit denen will ich auch echt nicht auf einer auf einem Straßenzug unterwegs sein.
Das ist richtig, aber also.
Wie gesagt, ich bin selber noch nicht mal hingegangen. Ich habe keinen Finger für dieses Synchron gemacht. Ich bin nicht hingegangen, ich habe noch nicht mal irgendwie in einem Twitter für dazu aufgerufen, das Ding zu besuchen, ja. Ähm,
Trotzdem muss man eben auch aus politisch äh strategischer Erwägung da eben dran gehen. Und wenn da halt Spacken auftauchen,
Ja, die irgendwie ähm teilweise sehr verquere äh Bis ähm.
Ähm ja, nicht haltbare politische Positionen irgendwie vertreten oder Auffassung, was in der Welt denn geschehen ist. Da musst du eben zusehen, dass du mehr bist als die,
Ja, aber du kannst ja nicht als
kannst ja nicht dich selber als betrachten und sagen, unter den sechseinhalbtausend Leuten sind aber fünfhundert, die einen an einer Waffel haben, trotzdem aber die Freiheit haben, äh sich dorthin zu bewegen. Ähm und die halten aber blöde Plakate hoch und ich habe Angst, mit denen auf einem Bild zu sein. Da musste eben zusehen, dass ein größeres Plakat hast.
Ja und das, dass sie die halt ähm dass du dich derer äh als Bewegung,
Entledigst oder dass du deine Bewegung so groß machst, dass dass diese Person dadrin keine ähm keine nennenswerte,
Menge mehr stellen. Und dadurch, dass äh Menschen dann eben nicht hingehen, würden sie aber auch genau dazu, dass das eben passiert, dass das denen da das das Feld überlassen wird. Und Freiheit statt Angst ist eben leider
nach wie vor eine Marke, die ähm,
ähm mediale Beachtung befindet und du die eben auch mediale Beachtung findet, wenn da keiner hingeht,
Ja, bei anderen Demonstrationen hast du teilweise das Glück oder die haben das Problem, dass sie sagen,
ja wir wir hoffen dass unsere Demonstration überhaupt die Schwelle reißt mediale Berichterstattung hervorzurufen.
Das hat sie ja übrigens geschafft, also in die Tagesschau war die Veranstaltung jetzt auch.
Richtig, weil die Freiheit statt Angstdemonstration,
Dieses Problem nicht hat, der hat halt andere Problem, sie hat hoffentlich schreiben, die hoffentlich kriegen wir genug Leute, damit nicht nachher in der Tagesschau gesagt wird, ist keiner hingegangen,
Die das, du hast halt nicht mehr die Wahl zu sagen, ähm wir wir machen die Freiheit statt Angstdemo nicht. Oder wir lassen die sang und klanglos ähm nicht stattfinden.
Dann dann ist aber besser äh man skippt das,
als als dass man sich permanent jetzt in den Druck sieht, äh so, oh Gott, jetzt wir müssen noch halbwegs stark äh wirken, dann dann bist du ja einfach in so einer Schleife gefangen. Ich meine, dann geht es einfach wirklich nur noch um diesen Event als Seuchen und überhaupt nicht mehr, worum's eigentlich geht,
weil wenn man jetzt äh ich sage einfach mit Lat-Demos kriegst du den Drops nicht gelutscht. So, ja,
irgendwie toll finden und es ist schön, dass wir uns alle in Berlin treffen und wenn's Wetter gut war, haben wir sind wir noch ein bisschen gebräunt, aber äh das hilft nicht weiter
So, deswegen Energie in andere äh Demonstrationsformen, die auch durchaus im öffentlichen Raum stattfinden können,
aber die man sehr viel mehr äh Guerilla-mäßig organisiert und wo man vielleicht äh an einer Stelle mal eine eine gute Idee entwickelt, die dann eben auch von vielen kleinen Gruppen, an vielen Orten immer wieder zum richtigen Zeitpunkt in der Öffentlichkeit, wie
wiederholt werden kann.
Ist ein valider Punkt. Findet aber genauso wenig statt. Und,
es ist nicht so, als wären irgendwie Aktivisten Ressourcen gerade besonders äh blockiert äh mit der, mit der Freistaat Angst gewesen, bis auf irgendwie ein paar Leute aus Bielefeld, die das ganze Ding schultern, ja?
Es ist nämlich so, dass äh eben, was weiß ich, Organisationen, in denen ich dann eben auch vernetzt bin. Die haben eben als Alternative gar nichts gemacht,
So und ich bin da das beste Beispiel dafür. Ich habe nichts anderes gemacht. Ich hätte was anders machen können. Ich hätte eine coolere Aktion machen können, aber die die tatsächliche Entscheidung, vor der die Menschen eben stehen, ist,
hingehen oder nicht, die Aktion machen oder nicht. Natürlich kann man sagen, wir könnten coolere Aktionen machen, wir könnten mehr Aktionen machen und so weiter, passiert aber eben auch nicht.
So und dann dann muss man sich doch irgendwann im September hinstellen und oder Ende August hinstellen und sagen, okay, wenn.
Wir alle, nichts Geiles auf die Beine gestellt haben in der ganzen Zeit,
Was ja auch nicht stimmt, ne? CCC hat ja äh gerade dieses Snowdenfeld medial sehr erfolgreich beackert.
Ähm sehr viel Aufmerksamkeit für für ähm Äußerungen und Aktionen in dem Umfeld bekommen, ne. So, aber,
Wie gesagt, die die Alternative zu sagen, ich äh ich gehe da nicht hin, weil ähm das müsste eigentlich alles anders sein, aber ich mach's auch nicht anders, ist eben auch eine die,
als ja unsolidarisch äh kritisiert werden kann. Wie gesagt, auf der Position bin ich ja selber, ne, aber ich ich finde's halt ähm.
Ja, unsolidarisch, weiß ich nicht, äh nur weil die anderen jetzt der Meinung sind, das wäre jetzt die beste und einzig äh denkbare Ausdrucksform.
Hat doch hat doch keiner gesagt, keiner hat gesagt, dass das die die beste und einzig wahre Aktion ist. Das hat selbst selbst Paddelun von äh Digitalcourage hat das nicht gesagt,
im Prinzip der Einzige ist, der das Ding oder die einzige Organisation ist, die das Ding noch irgendwie ähm versucht am Kacken zu.
Aber in dem Moment, wo du Solidarität einforderst, ja, dann klingt das so, als als äh müsste ich sozusagen darauf reagieren.
Nee, habe ich auch nicht, habe nur gesagt, dass man das als unsolidarisch bezeichnen kann, was wir getan haben. Geh nicht hin, machen nix anderes besser.
Wir machen hier was besser, aber äh ja, also es ist viel zu einfach äh mit diesem äh Unsinn, das würde ich halt so nicht nicht gelten lassen, weil.
Wenn wenn mich was nicht zieht, dann zieht's mich halt nicht
So und dann dann ist es nicht meine Schuld, dass ich da äh mich nicht ausreichend für begeistern kann. Ist so und das scheint ja auch sehr vielen anderen zu gehen, ja? Äh sonst würden wir nicht über äh limitierte Teilnehmerzahlen
reden. Ich meine, man kann jetzt auch mal sagen, sind sechstausendfünfhundert Leute nicht, nein, sind es nicht. Ja, das sind immer noch sechstausendfünfhundert Leute,
Also denkt ihr mal, was aus, wofür du sechstausendfünfhundert Leute auf die Straße kriegst, ist jetzt auch nicht so einfach. Von daher würde ich auch nicht sagen, dass es keine Unterstützung hat. Ja, das läuft so irgendwie für sich, aber ich finde nicht, dass es jetzt irgendwie äh den Eindruck macht, dass wenn man da jetzt reininvestiert,
dann wird das schon was, sondern ich finde das irgendwie ein ausgelutschtes Ding, sorry. Also es ist einfach so mein.
Sehe ich ja genauso. Ich sage nur, dass es halt an an unseren an den politischen Zielen.
Und an den politischen Aktionen der äh äh Gruppen einen Klotz am Bein ist. Ja und zwar ein blöder Klotz am Bein ist, dass dass man sich damit die Leute ähm,
oder die Politiker, die auf die man versucht Einfluss zu nehmen, die betrachten natürlich sehr, sehr genau,
mit mit was für einer Gruppe sie da zu tun haben,
und wie gefährlich die Innen sein kann. Und das war äh bislang her, dass Sascha Lobe da mal, glaube ich, auf Spiegel Online ein sehr äh schönen Artikel zugeschrieben hat. Wo er also sagte, so diese diese Netz,
Lobby, Netzgemeinde, ist eine relativ kleine, relativ äh Arme.
Und mittellose Vereinigungen, die gemessen an ihren Ressourcen ziemlich enormen Einfluss
entwickelt, ja? Also überlege mal allein, wie oft CCC-Leute in Bundestagsausschüssen sind, da investieren oder wie oft äh äh unsere Position in einer äh Nachrichtensendung wie der Tagesschau ähm,
äh vertreten werden. Ja, da investieren PR-Agenturen, die wissen, was,
zehn Sekunden Tagesschau. Die kostet, da müssen die paar Leute äh ein Jahr für beschäftigen, die da irgendwie mit Konzepten drauf hinarbeiten so ungefähr, ne? Also das sind die absoluten Perlen der der Medienaufmerksamkeit, die wir teilweise,
mit sehr kleinen Ressourcen abfrühstücken. So und dann ist es natürlich einmal im Jahr.
Ist es für für die gesamte Bewegung recht schädlich, wenn zu erkennen ist, die haben sich sehr viel Mühe gegeben zu zu motivieren.
Ähm.
Kriegen nicht nicht wirklich nennenswert Leute auf die Straße. Das ist was, womit du halt äh dann auch in der politischen Arbeit,
konfrontiert bist. Das ist alles, was ich sage. Und deswegen ist es ein, es ist ein ein unliebsamer Klotz am Bein, dass man da diese Aktionsform hat, die einerseits äh,
in ihrer Wirksamkeit ähm,
durchaus in Frage gestellt werden kann, äh die ähm auch zu recht langweilig ist, um deren Organisationen irgendwie viele viel Zwietracht entsteht. Ähm.
Und das ist halt eine eine, ja, eine Liebility auf einmal geworden, die äh die, die man jetzt auf einmal da in seinem Portfolio hat.
Ja und dann einfach, dann sage ich halt einfach äh sein lassen, weil in dem Moment, wo du's sein lässt, wo einfach sagt, okay, nächstes Jahr machen wir das einfach mal nicht,
uns was Neues aus, wir wissen zwar noch nicht was, was es ist, aber jetzt könnt ihr ja mal alle darüber nachdenken. Das ist so erzeugt man einfach ein Vakuum.
Ist immer super, weil danach macht's. Und irgendwas schießt da rein und wir wissen nicht was.
Ja, es äh ja, ja, also grundsätzlich,
teile ich die Ansicht, aber grade so ein Vorschlag ist dann wiederum sehr schwer unterzubringen in einer äh Organisationsstruktur wie einem Demobündnis, ja, wo es eventuell auch äh Gruppierungen gibt, deren.
Die die Beteiligung an dieser äh Demonstration für ihre Organisation als mehr oder weniger äh überlebensnotwendig äh sehen.
Dann tue ich ihn vielleicht noch einen Gefallen damit, nehme ich das einfach ignorieren.
Ja. Okay, also Freiheit Angst Timo.
Das war's dazu. Hören wir auch noch mehr Themen, oder? Wir haben mehr Themen. Ja, ja.
Wir haben mehr Themen. Cybercrime.
Da ist er wieder, der Cyber.
Herr Seiber.
Machen wir nochmal den an.
Ich gucke mal, müsste gehen. Ich habe eigentlich.
Ich habe auch gerade eine Antwort bekommen auf einen äh retweite Tweet von äh Steffen Seibert.
Ähm ich habe meinen ähm meinen Player hier gerade leider ausgemacht schon.
Da fragt einer, aus welchem Witzebuch haben sie denn das abgeschrieben?
Das Witzebuch heißt digitale Agenda, ist äh kostenlos erhältlich bei ihrer Bundesregierung. Aber wir wollten jetzt nicht über die Agenda reden, sondern wir reden jetzt über die tatsächliche Bedrohung äh ein Lagebild wurde äh erstellt.
Ja genau, von von zwei von zwei Gruppierungen, von zwei Lobbyisten, von zwei Cyber äh Lobbys und zwar ähm,
der der Bitcom, der Branchenverband Bitcom hat eine ein so ein Umfrageergebnis,
veröffentlicht und das Bundeskriminalamt gleichzeitig seinen jährlichen äh Lagebericht, der hieß vorher irgendwie I und K Berichte. So, den haben wir auch, glaube ich, jedes Jahr hier dann äh kurz äh mit unserer Aufmerksamkeit.
Und jetzt heißt es Cyber-Bericht oder was?
Lagebild, Cybercrime oder so, ja, also müssen ist äh eigentlich egal, wie das heißt. Das Entscheidende ist, was drinsteht so. Die Bitcom, der Bitcom fangen wir mal damit an, die haben tausend Internetnutzer befragt. Wir haben tausend. Kennst du noch Werner Schulze, Erde?
Erde Familienduell. Eintausend Internetnutzer haben wir gefragt. Nennen sie etwas, das fiept.
Muss, dann stehen die Leute so gegenüber. Und dann sagen die was und die müssen quasi die die,
die meist genannte Antwort geben, ja? Und dann kriegst du und dann sagt er, dann steht Werner Schütze Erde, der sagt, Gabi sagt, nun,
Sagten auch und am Computer an der Wand nennen sie niemand, oh Publikum, oh und dann sagt der Nächste fiept Tinnitus. Und dann irgendwie so Franksackten Tinnitus,
Sagten auch. Und dann kommt irgendwie so, bring, bring, bring, bring, fünf Leute, immerhin, ja? Und dann.
Klatsch, klatsch, klatsch, klatsch, klatsch.
Eintausend Internetnutzer haben wir gefragt.
Ähm und zwar, ob sie zum Beispiel innerhalb der vergangenen zwölf Monate Opfer von Cyber Crime geworden sind. Und rate mal, wie viele,
Menschen in den letzten vergangenen zwölf Monaten offen von Cybercrime geworden sind. Fünfundfünfzig Prozent.
Und dann sagt der Bitcoin Präsident Doktor Dieter Kempf, Cyberkriminalität kann jeden treffen,
und äh das ist natürlich eine Aussage, die äh dem Bitcom gelegen kommt, weil seine Mitglieder äh natürlich äh äh damit äh Geld verdienen mit solchen Ängsten, weil sie.
Doch jetzt nur Zufall.
Zum Beispiel äh Virenprogramme verkaufen und stellt sich heraus.
Viren entfernen. Virenschutzprogramme.
Wir haben Schutzprogramme, zum Beispiel, ne? Mein Computer wurde mit Programmen, zum Beispiel Viren infiziert, sagen vierzig Prozent der eintausend äh befragten Personen.
Ja? Und dann hast du halt äh.
Wenn wir dann mal in einen Bereich kommen, wo du also ich meine, wenn du ein Virus hast, ja, das kannst du streng genommen als Cybercrime betrachten, da hat jemand die Integrität deines Informationsverarbeitendes, denn Systems kompromittiert gegen deinen Willen,
Ähm aber wenn du dann, sage ich mal, in dem Bereich kommst, wo man jetzt,
klassisch Cybercrime sagen würde. Ja, ich bin Opfer eines Betrugs beim Online-Banking geworden
vier Prozent. Ich habe durch Programme oder in Folge eines Datendiebstahls einen finanziellen Schaden erlitten, zwei Prozent. Das sind dann, glaube ich, schon eher realistische Zahlen, die da natürlich dann aufgrund ihrer Niedrigkeit auch nochmal einer äh gewissen äh Schwankungen unterliegen.
Ähm.
Vor allem auch aufgrund der Befragten Teilnehmer, also tausend Internetnutzer, hm.
Aber der entscheidende Punkt ist natürlich der der Bitcoin will Dienstleistungen und Produkte verkaufen und äh dann sagt nämlich auch der Doktor, der Professor Dieter Kempf, interne Indizer können sich gut schützen
äh wenn sie die Gefahren kennen und sich achtsam verhalten, ja, also das ist äh die haben natürlich da ein äh finanzielles Interesse in diesem Bereich. Ähm.
Ich persönlich kenne echt niemanden, der äh.
Also ich muss wirklich überlegen, ob ich irgendjemanden kenne, der mal Opfer von von einem Cyber Crime angriff wurde.
Ich kenne ja noch nicht mal Leute, die Viren haben.
Ja, weil du,
Okay. Das äh das sagen die ja auch nicht, ne. Also das wissen ja die die wer sich Viren einfängt, gehört dann zu der Gruppe, die auch nicht mehr ein ist, dass es ihnen passiert ist, ne, aber ähm.
Vierzig Prozent, Viren und Spam, ich meine, wenn man sich die Verbreitung des Windows-Betriebssystems und dessen Update-Status ähm äh Patchlevel irgendwie anschaut, dann halte ich das für eine realistische Zahl. Aber Viren und Spam, ja, Spam, na ja
Also, eine relativ unseriöse äh Studie.
Von Spam ist ja aber nicht die Rede.
Stimmt. Das war im Netz Politik ORG.
Bei Spam hätten wir ja nun wirklich hundert Prozent und äh das würde dann irgendwie auch nicht so richtig.
So, aber ich will noch das noch ins Verhältnis setzen. Also nehmen wir mal diese Zahl. Es wird gesagt, fünfundfünfzig Prozent der
Internetnutzer sind, in den vergangenen zwölf Monaten Opfer, krimineller Vorfälle geworden. Wie gesagt, der kriminelle Vorfall hier mit der Infektion durch ein Virus schon sehr äh sehr breit äh definiert.
Ähm und eine Studie von einer äh Gruppe, die eben Dienstleistungen verkaufen möchte. Jetzt kommt das BKA und sagt ähm.
Sie definieren Cyber-Kriminalität und Anna hat äh bisellig von sich das irgendwie mal angeschaut, hat unter der Definition dann irgendwie auch Dinge wie Fahrrad, Diebstahl und Tankbetrug gefunden. Und jetzt BKA hatte irgendwie ein Problem.
Um etwas. Fahrraddiebstahl.
Ja, Google Maps äh Koks oder so, mit dem geklauten Fahrrad dich über Google Maps nach Hause äh ruhten lässt, klarer Fall von Cybercrime. Ich.
Bezog. Mein Computer hat kein Benzin mehr.
Ich will ich will lieber mal mich nur auf die Zahlen konzentrieren. Ähm.
So, jetzt hat das BKA ein Problem. Die müssen jedes Jahr kommen und irgendwie eine Dramameldung bringen zu Cybercrime. Und jetzt war ihr Problem,
das ist irgendwie 'ne Steigerung von rund einem Prozent gab gegenüber zweitausendzwölf und das ist natürlich 'ne das ist 'ne Schwankung die ist natürlich
im Fehlertoleranzbereich und deswegen haben sie dann einfach nochmal die alten Zahlen gesagt, ja, zwei, im Vergleich zum letzten Jahr nur um ein Prozent, aber wenn wir gegenüber zweitausendneun
sind's nämlich zwanzig Prozent,
und dann verweist der gute Herr Zirke auf eine Studie, in der sie äh von dem Dunkelfeld, wo sie das Dunkelfeld erforscht haben, ja?
Das Dunkelfeld.
Sehr interessant, das Dunkelfeld, also eine man äh versucht statistisch zu schätzen, wie groß der Bereich ist,
den man nicht kennt. Also es ist natürlich kannst du, gibt's Methoden für, aber ist natürlich sehr ähm.
Sie haben sozusagen in den Cyber hineingeschaut.
Ja und sie haben, sie sagen also, nur neun Prozent des äh Cyber Crimes äh kommt zur Anzeige. Und jetzt stellt man sich natürlich dann die Frage, warum wird es wohl nicht angezeigt?
Und deren ähm äh deren Argumentation wird natürlich sein, ähm ja, weil die Menschen äh wissen, dass wir ihnen nicht helfen können, weil wir keine Vorratsdatenspeicherung haben, ja? Oder so, ne? Also so,
Ja, so argumentieren die.
Sicher, klar. Die andere Sache ist natürlich, dass die Mensch, ich meine, es kommt einfach keiner auf die Idee,
zu sagen, ich habe sollte man eigentlich mal machen. Ich habe einen Virus auf meinem Computer, ich gehe zur Polizei. Sehe ich überhaupt nicht ein. Ich bin Opfer von Kriminalität geworden. Ja, auch Kriminalität, ja. Ich meine, Kriminalität ist ein großes Wort, ja. Ähm,
Äh geh mal hin, mach mal eine Anzeige bis Opfer von Kriminell, Cyber Crime. Cyber Crime. Ähm,
So, ne, das da werden also sehr gezielt sehr sehr spezielle Zahlen genutzt, mit sehr äh komischen.
Definition und natürlich das BKA will Vorratsdatenspeicherung und Überwachung, es kann nur das und es will immer nur das wollen,
die betreiben da 'ne Mithilfe ihrer Erhebung, wirklich 'ne
krasse Propaganda. Das war ja auch konzertiert ja Bitcom und BKA am gleichen Tag, ja? Um die Medien eben auch entsprechend zu ähm,
Zu nutzen. Ich habe ja gerade davon gesprochen, wie viel das Leuten wert ist, einen Satz in der Tagesschau unterzubringen, ne? Das wird der Bitcom nicht
Durch Zufall irgendwie die Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass die aus Versehen äh zusammen mit dem BKA ihren Kriminalitätsreport veröffentlichen, ist äußerst gering, ne? Ein eins durch dreihundert äh fünfundsechzig.
Und das BKA haben unsere Daten da.
Genau. Und ähm da habe ich dann nochmal darüber nachgedacht über die Agenda des BKA, denn,
Sie wollen ja im Prinzip Ermittlungswerkzeuge haben, die technisch möglich, aber äh verfassungsrechtlich verboten sind. Und das ist eine Situation, die sie in eigentlich in keinem anderen Bereich haben.
Außer in diesem äh außer in dem technischen Bereich. Ich meine, die können machen ihre Funkzellenabfragen, da haben sie nicht wirklich nennenswerten Gegenwind.
Ähm die machen diese äh Rasterfahndung mit ihr mit den Fotos, die sie von Autos an an bei der Autobahn machen. Ja, die äh,
können den Menschen die Türen eintreten, die können die Menschen mit äh stillen SMS überwachen, die haben wirklich es gibt,
kaum etwas, kaum ein Ermittlungswerkzeug, das den nicht letztendlich zur Hand äh.
Gereicht wird, ja? Dann teilweise mit Richter, Vorbehalt und so, aber die stehen.
Eigentlich im bei jeder bei bei allem bei allen Kriminalitätsbereichen haben sie auch alle Ermittlungswerkzeuge, die möglich sind.
Ja, den verbietet keiner ähm irgendwie Massen Gentests oder so, wenn sie irgendwie das Dorf äh oder oder den Landstrich äh zu, zur freiwilligen äh Gentest einladen. Da geht denen auch keiner aufs Dach. Die können das alles eigentlich immer machen
nur wenn's um um das geht, was Cyber-Kriminalität ist
äh da da sind, da gibt es überhaupt etwas, wo sie sagen können, da gibt es da gibt es theoretisch denkbare Ermittlungswerkzeuge, die uns nicht zur Verfügung stehen
Oder habe ich diese These zu gewagt?
Kommen wir jetzt auch erstmal so äh stehen lassen. Ich finde das eine ganz interessante Sichtweise habe ich so noch nicht drüber nachgedacht.
Sicherlich haben sie auch in anderen Bereichen durchaus äh Grenzen, also auch was so was ich ausüben von Gewalt und das Durchführen von Hausdurchsuchung betrifft, man ist dies ja auch begrenzt.
Generell gibt's das Instrument.
Begrenzung und eine praktische, ne? Also ausüben von Gewalt sehe ich jetzt nicht großartig begrenzt in der Realität durch Polizisten
Also das hieße ja, dass es dann müsste es ja Sanktionen geben gegen Polizisten, die dieses Recht irgendwie ähm,
zu Unrecht in Anspruch genommen haben, ja, also da müsste es ja, sage ich mal,
Fälle von Polizeigewalt geben, Fälle von Ungerechtigkeit ungerechtfertigter Polizeigewalt geben, die in irgendeiner Form geahndet werden. Und das hast du ja nicht.
Weil zum Beispiel auf Demonstrationen.
Beispielsweise. Hm, naja, okay, aber ähm,
Genau, sie können dann eben unterreglementierten äh,
Bedingungen können sie Haus durchsuchen unter reglementierten Bedingungen dürfen sie äh von Knüppel und Schusswaffe Gebrauch machen. Und äh die Fragen, die nachher gestellt werden, kann immer keiner beantworten. Aber,
bestimmten äh Bereichen im Internet haben sie eben technisch denkbare Ermittlungsmethoden, die ihn einfach grundsätzlich nicht zur Verfügung stehen.
Das ist deren Situation. Und dafür äh arbeiten sie das zu ändern.
Ähm man kann diese Statistiken immer noch sehr viel mit mit tausenden Fragen überziehen und man kann ähm.
Da wirklich lange dran rum analysieren. Das habe ich auch früher immer gemacht, wenn die mit ihren Statistiken kamen, dann auch methodische Fehler und so äh aus ausdiskutiert. Ähm.
Habe ich diese Woche nicht gemacht. Ich denke, man man muss eben auch immer wissen, wer die Statistik gefälscht hat, die einem da gerade vorgelegt wird und welche Aussagen diese äh Interessengruppe oder diese Person da gerade äh treffen möchte.
Das haben wir da glaube ich ganz gut äh mit abgedeckt, oder? Ja. Ja. Kommen wir zur erfolgreicheren äh Maßnahmen.
Das ist geil. Das ist ja was, wo wir äh, wo wir vor einigen Folgen noch drüber äh debattiert haben, nämlich die VG Media.
Mit ihrer Kartellbeschwerde gegen Google,
Wir erinnern uns, die VG Media als Zusammenschlussinteressenzusammenschluss der äh,
Presseverleger, die gesagt hat, okay, hey, wir wollen das äh das einnehmen von,
Leistung, Schutzgeld, äh irgendwie vereinheitlichen, ne, da irgendwie eine eine in eine ähm,
äh Gesellschaft für Gründen, so eine Art GEMA für Journalisten, für Verlage. Ähm.
Und ähm,
Da hatte ich ja sogar auch deren Argumentation hier äh zumindest rechtlich ähm nachvollzogen und verteidigt, dass sie sagen, okay, wenn wir das Recht dazu haben.
Ähm Geld dafür zu verlangen, dass äh,
Suchmaschinen, unsere Auszüge unserer Texte, ähm archivieren und äh darstellen. Dann ist es ein Kartellrechtlich brisanter Schritt, wenn Google uns,
dazu zwingt, auf dieses Recht zu verzichten. Ja, also die Argumentation ist, wir genießen ein Leistungsschutzrecht für die ähm,
Für die Artikel, die wir veröffentlichen, das heißt, wir können Menschen und äh Konzernengeld abnehmen, die diese Ausschnitte zu ihrem, in ihren kommerziellen Zwecken ähm nutzen,
Google, der Betrieb, der Google Suchmaschine ist ein kommerzieller Zweck, das heißt, wir haben das Recht dazu, äh von Google Geld dafür zu verlangen,
ja? Und dann würde man Google natürlich äh sagen, okay, dann hat Google aber natürlich auch das Recht, dieses Geld nicht zu bezahlen. Allerdings, wenn Google den Suchmaschinenmarkt äh und den den,
den Interneteingang zu irgendwie mehr als neunzig Prozent kontrolliert. Kann man sagen, Google nutzt da seine Markt beherrschende Stellung aus, um seine
in dem Falle. Geschäfts,
äh Partner oder Geschäftsgegner die Verlage in eine dazu zu zwingen, ihnen etwas ähm.
Billig zu geben oder kostenlos zu geben für das sie eigentlich Geld bekommen sollten, na? Dass sie quasi die erpressen mit dem,
zerstören ihres Geschäftsmodells. Nämlich, dass sie sagen, ey, dann erscheint dein Mist eben nicht mehr bei uns, das ist völlig egal und das kann halt eine eine Suchmaschine mit mit zehn Prozent Marktanteil machen,
Suchmaschine mit neunzig Prozent Marktanteil eben nicht, weil man argumentieren könnte, dass sie da ihre Markt beherrschende Stellung ausnutzt. So und damit sind da entsprechend lautete auch die Beschwerde der VG Media.
Und ähm.
Dann hat das Kartellamt gesagt, die Ankunft Anknüpfungspunkte für ein eventuell Kartell rechtsrelevantes Verhalten von Google, beruhen teilweise nur auf Mutmaßungen.
Das eigentliche Beschwerdeziel bleibt unklar.
Das heißt, das der sagt, folgt genau meiner meiner dargestellten Argumentation nicht und sagt, Moment mal, Leute, ihr habt euch ein Gesetz zurecht lobbyiert äh und wollt da jetzt irgendwie ähm,
Geld bekommen für jemanden, der, wenn man's mal genau betrachtet, eine Dienstleistung,
euch bringt, nämlich euch Nutzer zuzuspielen. Also die Argumentation, die ähm,
In dem Zusammenhang immer wieder schön äh zu nennen ist, dass äh ich glaube, auf Mario Sixt, das klingt der Vergleich zurück, dass der der Betreiber eines Restaurants ähm,
den Taxifahrer dafür zu Kasse bittet, dass er ihm Gäste vor die Tür fährt. Das war glaube ich der Vergleich von von Mario in dem Zusammenhang.
Genau und jetzt kommt der Taxifahrer nicht mehr und jetzt verklagen sie das Taxiunternehmen darauf, dass die äh dass sie keine Gäste dahin fahren, obwohl die ganz woanders hin wollen. Also.
Und ungefähr so hat die, das war also die, die sehr viel einfachere und unkompliziertere äh Argumentationen, die ähm dem das Kartellamt,
hier teilt und das anders, das wirklich sehr schöne ist. Ähm ist das das Kartellamt dann schreibt so äh ach so und übrigens äh VG Media ähm,
ob eure Verlegergemeinschaft da, die ausschließlich sich auf das Leistungsschutzrecht konzentriert, nicht eventuell auch ein verbotenes Kartell ist.
Das können wir uns ja vielleicht auch nochmal anschauen, wenn ihr uns weiter auf den Sa.
Es ist wirklich lustig.
Und das da haben sie halt natürlich, da haben sie einen Punkt, ne, dass sie sagen, okay, da schließen sich die Verlage zusammen, um einen Einheitspreis zu diktieren
um sich selber zu einer Markt dominierenden äh Einheit zu zusammenzufügen, die geschlossen auftritt und die letztendlich nichts anderes macht, als eine Preisabsprache.
Also sowas nennt man ja mindestens eine Klatsche, wenn nicht sogar ein Schuss in Fuß, wenn das irgendwie noch so weitergehen sollte. Ich bin in gewisser Hinsicht beruhigt, als dass ich ja eigentlich schon bei der beim Zustande komme des Gesetzes.
Also ich konnte mir einfach nicht vorstellen,
wie man das durchziehen kann so und dann wurde es natürlich durchgezogen, haben das hier auch alles äh begleitet und es lässt einen in so einem Kopf schütteln äh zurück. Schön, dass aber irgendwie noch so ein paar Leute gibt, die äh zumindest halbwegs klar sind,
oder zumindest nicht bereit sind, sich äh die Sicht vollständig vernibeln zu lassen.
Ja.
Tja, jetzt bin ich ja mal gespannt, wie sie darauf reagieren, weil jetzt haben sie nämlich zunächst einmal gar nix. Und vor allem sieht es ja auch schwer danach aus, als ob dieser Weg jetzt nach der Antwort.
Würde ich erstmal einen größeren Bogen um das Kartell abmachen.
Ja, weil vor allem, also das ist jetzt auch so ein äh also nicht nur, dass sie damit jetzt keinen Erfolg hatten. Es ist überhaupt nicht absehbar,
also das können sie jetzt nicht ein bisschen modifizieren. So nach dem Motto war etwas unscharf formuliert. Äh wir haben jetzt nochmal ein paar Kommas äh hinzugefügt. Lest es euch doch noch mal durch. Da lachen die sich halt einfach schlapp, wenn die das sehen.
Von daher ist es irgendwie jetzt raus aus der äh Nummer. Ich frage mich halt nur, ob die eigentlich selber davon ausgegangen sind, da Erfolg zu haben.
Ich gehe, natürlich sind die davon ausgegangen. Das war der einzige das war ja schon immer der die einzige,
Theoretisch denkbare Möglichkeit, wie man dem,
Leistungsschutzrecht für Presseverlage irgendwie zu einer äh Wirksamkeit verhelfen könnte. Es war immer klar, dass wir gesagt haben,
dann mach Google den Mist einfach zu oder setzt den ein entsprechenden Knebelvertrag entgegen, dass sie sagen, okay Freunde, unterschreibe bitte einmal hier, dass ihr auf alle äh Ansprüche verzichtet.
Dann nehmen wir euch weiter auf, ansonsten fliegt ihr eben raus. Und das ist, ne,
Das ist die richtige, der, der richtige logische Schritt und gegen den kannst du dich nur wehren, wenn ähm.
Wenn du irgendwie ein, einen zweiten Arm hast und das ist eben wäre jetzt hier das Kartellrecht gewesen, wenn sie's hinbekommen hätten. Und ich ich persönlich glaube, dass mit diesem,
Mit dieser Antwort, mit diesem Brief des Kartellamtes, dieses gesamte über zwei Jahre, drei Jahre, vier Jahre getriebene Lobbyprojekt. Ähm.
Endlich seinen viel zu späten Tod gefunden hat.
Dass es schon soweit ist.
Siehst du noch irgendeine andere Möglichkeit?
Ianal, ja, also ich meine, es droht ja immer noch, ich meine, das Gesetz gilt ja noch,
Also unabhängig davon, dass es ihnen jetzt nicht gelingt, äh äh Google da äh irgendeine Fernbedienung über Google äh zu erhalten, ähm bleibt ja immer noch die Verunsicherung des Marktes.
Also es ist ja immer noch äh so, dass dass hier einfach wieder an zahlreichen Stellen Geschäftsmodelle überhaupt erst gar nicht äh angedacht werden.
Der Flurschaden, den stelle ich ja nicht in Frage.
Ja genau, so und ähm.
Ich glaube aber nicht, dass der Flurschaden das Ziel dieser Initiative.
Ja, nee, natürlich, äh, das ist, das ist natürlich nicht, die Frage, trotz alledem könnten sie ja immer noch Tanzheben einfordern,
Also das könnten sie ja irgendwo probieren, da wo sie einen offensichtlichen äh Verstoß sehen. Na ja, was weiß ich, dann sind irgendwie fünf Zeichen zu viel aus der äh Headline äh kopiert worden, ja.
Oder überhaupt die Headlines und dann versuchen sie es einfach so krass ausliegen zu lassen, so und weiß der Geier, äh bei irgendeinem Gericht äh in Deutschland hat man ja durchaus auch mal gute Karten. Es gibt ja da durchaus so urheberrechts, ne?
Freundliche ähm Gerichtsbarkeiten. Ich glaube, wir hatten über Hamburg schon häufiger gesprochen in dem Zusammenhang. Müssen wir sehen.
Du würdest also argumentieren, sie können also sie könnten jetzt irgendwie noch versuchen, sich irgendwie gegenseitig damit äh,
zu äh zerfleischen. Klar, das das wäre noch möglich, aber ähm wohin die Reise gehen sollte mit dieser ganzen Initiative, war doch schon irgendwie,
über lange Zeit sehr, sehr offensichtlich. Die haben spezifisch eine anti-Google Kampagne gefahren,
Die haben's spezifisch über Google argumentiert und die haben sogar diese Verwertungsgesellschaft irgendwie dann da positioniert, in der irgendwie alle entsprechend positionierten Verlagshäuser,
Mitglied geworden sind, um eine gemeinsam auftretende Gruppe zu haben, die als Definition als Verwertungsgesellschaft der Presseverlage,
Nur gegenüber anderen, also eben zweit- oder drittverwertern irgendwie auftreten.
Nee, aber nicht nicht vergessen, VW Media gibt's schon seit siebenundneunzig.
Stimmt, aber die haben sich diesen, dieses, dieses Ziel ist da jetzt angenommen, ne? Aber und es war sehr, sehr spezifisch. Hm, aber die haben sich quasi,
Aber also der, ich glaube, der der Weg war klar, dass sie genau den gehen wollten Leistungsschutzrecht bekommen über Kartellrecht, Google daran hindern, Google News einfach zuzumachen,
und dann irgendwie da eine Mark achtzig noch äh rauszubringen. Völlig bescheuerter Idee und entsprechend ist jetzt auch gescheitert.
Ja gut, aber was ist denn jetzt? Äh ich meine, das das Leistungsschutzrecht sagt aber im Prinzip ähm hier ihr dürft nicht ähm Ausschnitte nehmen. So. Google News tut aber genau das.
Ausschnitte werden angezeigt, so. Tun sie das jetzt nur noch von denen, die vorher gesagt haben, wir werden euch aber auch nichts in Rechnung stellen.
Das Leistungsschutzrecht sagt, die können grundsätzlich,
haben sie eine also haben darfst du das, darfst du nur kleinst Ausschnitte kostenfrei darstellen,
Das sagt das Leistungsschutzrecht. Ohne zu definieren, was ein Kleinstausschnitt ist. Ja
und ähm das wäre ja noch das Verfahren, was dann auch noch irgendwie geführt werden müsste, dass irgendein hohes Gericht entscheidet, ab wie viel äh Buchstabenkonsonanten oder äh Wörter ähm ein
Kleinstausschnitt, nicht mehr ein Kleinstausschnitt ist. Und ähm,
das Leistungsschutzrecht schließt ja nicht aus, dass du das Recht abtrittst. Du kannst natürlich machen, ich kann doch, also kannst ja jedes andere äh Urheberrecht auch abtreten,
Wenn ich sage, ich habe das Urheberrecht an an einer bestimmten, an einem bestimmten Erzeugnis und stelle dir das zur Verfügung und sage, schriftlich, du darfst es kostenlos nutzen, kann mich ja keiner dran hindern.
Genauso kann dich ja keiner daran hindern, dieses Verwertungsrecht eben abzutreten an eine Verwertungsgesellschaft, äh die dich dann, die dich und andere dann betrügt. Ja, wie die GEMA oder so, ne? Geht ja auch.
Auf jeden Fall haben wir jetzt irgendwie die Situation, dass äh Google wie Neo da jetzt in der Mitte von den ganzen Smith steht und irgendwie nur kurz so ein bisschen mit der Hand äh wedelt und sagt, komm doch.
Ja die Matrix zu. Ich würde das jetzt ja höchstens als ein kurzes Flimmern in der Matrix äh bezeichnen, zu dem die äh,
die Pressverlage da jetzt äh in der Lage war, ne? Es war so ganz kurz einmal so wie läuft der was? War da jetzt,
ja, mehr kann ich äh ja also ist irre, ne? Der Flurschaden,
Im Sinne von Rechtsunsicherheiten ist enorm. Das ist das, wofür wofür Leute wie ähm Till Kreuzer und die ganze Initiative gegen einen Leistungsschutzrecht immer gewarnt haben,
Da wurde äh eine ganze Jahresgehälter für irgendwelche Juristen und Lobbyisten verbrannt, das ist das das Jahres äh oder oder Jahrzehntprojekt des Christoph Käse. Da mussten, ne, da mussten sich irgendwie,
Menschen oder äh Daniel Schulz, der Presseschauer, ja, die haben sich jahrelang an diesem Scheiß abarbeiten müssen,
Ja? Und jetzt alles, was dabei rausgekommen ist, ist genau das, was sie immer gesagt haben.
Hm, ihr werdet da rechtlich scheitern und am Ende wird Google euch einfach äh die Listen oder ihr müsst irgendwie zusagen, ist eh kostenlos bereitzustellen und fertig ist sie, aber.
Welt nicht nur für alle anderen, sondern auch für euch selber zu einem schlechteren Ort gemacht. Herzlichen Glückwunsch. Und das ist schon enorm, was sie da für Kapazitäten auf eigener und auf anderer Seite äh gebunden haben für den Mist.
Ja und was das dann auch wiederum für ein sinnloser Druck auf die äh Bundesregierung ist, ja, die sich ja damit halt auseinandersetzen müssen, da einen Öffentlichkeitskampf gegen,
uns auch, hat für ein äh müssen und äh der ganzen damit verbundenen Verstimmung. Habt ihr jetzt davon,
Steffen Seibert dazu zu sagen hat.
Ähm ja,
Aber äh die Dysruption hört ja nicht äh auf, ja, es geht ja äh voran. Nach Google stehen schon andere Kandidaten bereit. Ähm
die Öffentlichkeit und vor allem auch die Wirtschaft neu aufzumischen. Ähm besonders,
unsympathischer Kandidat scheint die Firma Uber zu sein.
Ja, das ist äh das Uber wurde, also Uber wurde ja jetzt quasi die Ausführung dieses Dienstes verboten. Ich würde vielleicht vorher nochmal kurz ähm.
Nochmal drauf zu, so wo kam Uber her oder wo kommt diese oder her, ne?
Vielleicht nochmal auch kurz eher bisschen einleiten. Es gab ja früher, also keine Ahnung, vor zehn Jahren, wenn ich irgendwie äh größere äh innerdeutsche,
zurücklegen musste, dann bin ich auf äh Mitfahrgelegenheit DE gegangen oder so und habe dort ähm.
Bei der Mitfahrzentrale angerufen.
Ja, das war dann noch,
Internet und so, ne. Da gab es quasi Vermittlungsinstitutionen, die gesagt haben, wir äh,
Vermitteln dir Menschen, die mit diesen ganzen Autos, die sich in ihrem Privatbesitz befinden und leeren Plätzen irgendwie rüberfahren, dann wird ein Preis errechnet, der irgendwie grob auf
sage ich mal der vom Finanzamt erstatteten Steuerpauschale pro gefahrenen Kilometer, wo er dann irgendwie Abnutzung und Wartungen grob mit eingerechnet ist und Benzinverbrauch. Das Ganze wird durch die Anzahl von Personen im Fahrzeug,
geteilt und da kommt ein Preis raus, da fährst du irgendwie was weiß ich, von Berlin nach Köln für einen Zwanni oder so. Äh,
und es ist eine eine tatsächlich faire Angelegenheit, die sich da dann irgendwie ergibt, ja? Man konnte also die.
Die Preise, die sich dort ergeben haben, waren, ja, fair. Natürlich war es für den, für den Fahrer, wenn du jetzt als Fahrer sechshundert Kilometer fährst,
ne, nimmst drei Leute mit, jederzeit äh zwanzig, fünfundzwanzig Euro, hast du eigentlich auf die Schnelle,
die Spritkosten sogar äh drin oder machste sogar noch ein Plus mit dieser Fahrt, ne? Das hat natürlich dann auch ähm einige Menschen da ähm in so eine Art Professionalisierung getrieben, die irgendwie Außendienstmitarbeiter waren.
Und von mir aus Berlin Köln jeden Montag und Freitag fahren. Die haben das entsprechend bei äh Mitfahrzentrale drin gehabt und in ihrem Audi A6 äh vier Personen reingesetzt. Ne und pro Woche irgendwie ein schönes,
schöne äh hundertsechzig, hundertsiebzig Euro in die eigene Tasche gesteckt.
Sprüht ja eher auf die Firma ging, ne? So, da hattest du quasi dann schon so erste ähm Leute, die das Ding irgendwie professionalisiert haben, ähm die dann auch meistens die unangenehmeren äh Fahrer waren. Aber,
Das Ganze bewog sich ihr äh bewegte sich in so einem Rahmen, der irgendwie ja äh nicht als nicht-kommerziell.
Zu bezeichnen waren. Ähnlicher Dienst, den es, äh, den es gibt, der ja auch äh sehr geil ist, ähm die Website Couchsurfing, ne, wo du sagst, okay, du stellst ähm.
Eine Couch in deinem, in deiner Wohnung
zur Verfügung, die äh deine Stadt besuchen und ähm dann gibt's da irgendwie ein schönes social network drum herum, wo man sich irgendwie gegenseitig äh die die Charakterliche Integrität äh bescheinigt und dann ähm
kann man eben auch woanders hinreisen, ne. Habe ich auch schon in in mehreren Ländern der Welt gemacht. Triffst du irgendwie in der Regel aufgeschlossene coole Leute, pennst eins, zwei, drei Nächte bei denen.
Ein bisschen nachgelassen haben soll. Ich werde die Leute klagen.
Ja, natürlich, du hast ja auch äh Leute, die das irgendwie aus äh schmarotzen und du hast dann vor, ja jetzt auch irgendwie zwei, drei Jahren, wo das in Deutschland äh bekannter einen Dienst gehabt, der gesagt hat, okay, nee, wir vermieten unsere,
Wir vermieten das Zimmer in unserer Wohnung oder unsere ganze Wohnung zu preisen, die irgendwo zwischen Jugendherberge und Hotel liegen.
Kommerzialisieren quasi das Teilen. Und zwar mal ordentlich. Und er, das ist dann Airbnb, die gesagt haben, wunderbar. Wir bei uns gibt's solche Vermittlungen. Wir machen im Prinzip Couchtraffing mit bezahlen. Und äh nehmen ganz,
ganz nette, nicht besonders hohe, kommerziell absolut erträgliche Vermittlungsgebühren, kannste gut Geld mit verdienen,
vermietest irgendwie deine Wohnung für einen coolen Preis bis eine Woche weg, lässt die Leute für einen Fuffi die Nacht dadrin wohnen.
Grade Zweitwohnungen.
Zweitwohnung, großartig, ne?
Hast du relativ überschaubaren Aufwand. Am Ende musst du eine eine Ladung äh Wäsche waschen. So da kannst du richtig gut mit dazuverdienen als vor allem wenn du irgendwie viel reisender bist oder so, ne,
Nachbarschaftsauto war auch so ein Dienst, der das der das äh da ging's noch ums Auto verleihen. Ja, wo du wenn du jetzt irgendwie hast einen Transporter, brauchst du nur am Wochenende unter der Woche vermietest du den. So und das hat dann irgendwann natürlich auch zu Leuten geführt, die eben,
Zweitwohnungen zu dem einzigen Zweck hatten. Die zu, die unterzuvermieten.
Alter Mietvertrag hier in Berlin Ein-Zimmer-Wohnung, du hast aber jetzt ein Kind und eine Frau, hast aber die Wohnung behalten, weil die so billig ist, mietest die für was weiß ich, dreihundert äh warm, vermadetest die bei Airbnb deine,
Du bist gerade eh im Elternschutz und äh gehst da irgendwie alle paar Tage mal vorbei,
Ladung Wäsche und trotz neue äh Dingens aus, machst ein schönes Plus. Das Ganze beim amerikanischen Unternehmen, was dir die Kohle irgendwie über Paypal auszahlt. Muss man nicht mal Sorge haben, dass das Finanzamt irgendwie kommt und ähm.
Ein sehr nettes Zubrot durch, wenn ihr das dann halbwegs professionalisierst. Genauso dieses Nachbarschaftsauto, ne, Prinzip das äh das Gleiche, äh kommt jemand, holt sich deine Karre ab, zahlt am Ende irgendwie siebzig Euro dafür für einen Tag oder so was und hat äh
Freikilometer gehabt oder so und äh du hast gleichzeitig über den Diensteanbieter dann noch irgendwie so eine Haftpflichthaftpflichtzusatzversicherung gehabt, dass wenn der Typ, der äh dem du die Karre leihst, dann irgendwie die um Baum wickelt
ähm du dann, ne, auch noch versichert bist, ja?
Ähm und dann gab's jetzt eben diesen Dienst Uber, also Airbnb ist natürlich schon jetzt so, dass der der Dorn im Auge der äh der Hotels, der Hotelbetreiber. Ähm.
Und UVA sagt, wir greifen die Taxifahrer an.
Beziehungsweise zunächst haben wir ja auch so diese,
Genau so Chauffeurservices et cetera. Also ich glaube damit sind sie gestartet, ne? Mit eigener Flotte, schwarzer Autos, irgendwie wohlgekleidete äh Chauffeure sozusagen, so ein bisschen dieser Hauch von Luxus, aber jetzt nicht unbedingt zum Luxuspreis, sondern eher so ein bisschen Taxi-Plus.
Und ähm ja mit mehr Flexibilität, mit mehr Digitalisierung, mit äh besserer Vorbestell äh Möglichkeiten und so weiter. Da muss man auch,
unabhängig von der weiteren Abwägung äh dieses Vorfalls auch immer wieder sagen,
grad auch wieder das Taxiunternehmen. Das hat sie auch schon mit Mytaxi auch vorher schon abgezeichnet. Ja, also da gibt's einfach immer so diesen diesen äh diese
wie soll ich sagen, Innovationsbremse, die eingebaute, dass man dann sozusagen, also wenn man seine eigene Disruption nicht.
Vorantreibt. Dann treiben das andere voran. So und das äh zeigt sich bei mytaxi, das zeigt sich,
auch bei. Ist auch sehr interessant mein Taxi ist ja jetzt irgendwie komplett von Daimler übernommen worden, die am Anfang das nur mitfinanziert haben. Ähm da zeichnet sich auch grundsätzlich eine Veränderung
Mobilitätsmarkts ab, der sich auch schon mit Carsharing äh festmacht, sowohl dem äh stationsbasierten Carsharing, wie Flingstar,
oder eben dem Carsharing wie Car to go, Drive Now und so weiter, also da sind überall die großen Unternehmen drin, also zumindest Daimler und BMW haben das irgendwie jetzt schon seit langem vorangetrieben,
Ähm das ist auch grundsätzlich ein Trend und ich denke, da geht auch nichts dran vorbei. Ähm und ist vielleicht in gewisser Hinsicht auch gut, ja?
Das Taxisystem, so wie es heute ist, wird sich vermutlich ohnehin nicht so halten lassen.
Müssen wir vielleicht nochmal kurz erklären, wie das Taxisystem heute ist? Also du hast als Taxifahrer.
Braucht man eine Lizenz.
Eine Lizenz ähm
Beförderungsschein und irgendwie äh dann noch eine Extralizenz irgendwie nach Ortskenntnisprüfung und sowas alles. Und dann hast du irgendwann dein dein Taxi da stehen, das gehört hier in der Regel nicht, sondern du bist Angestellter bei einer ähm,
bei einer bei einem Taxibetreiber. Oder du bist sowas wie so ein selbstständiger, der quasi ein Taxi mietet
von einer Taxibetreiberfirma und der Taxibetreiberfirma dafür dann eine Provision zahlen muss, dass er dieses dieses Taxi gemietet hat und damit Einnahmen hat, also Taxifahrer werden von allen Seiten massiv gebeult. Ich habe mich da mal mit einem unterhalte mich eigentlich immer mit Taxifahrern
Und da äh gibt's also in Berlin ist die Situation so, dass es im Prinzip zwei Rufdienste gibt. Ähm.
Zwei große.
Sind's nur noch zwei, ja? Ja. Zweimal drei. Ich glaube, zwei haben sich jetzt nochmal verheiratet. Genau. Also Spreefunk und hm.
Gehören letztendlich, so habe ich das da verstanden, ungeprüft, letztendlich der gleichen Firma, die aber natürlich ein Teufel getan hat, die Dinger zu mergen,
weil die ja jede beide dieser Taxizentralen äh einhundertfünfzig Euro im Monat pro Fahrer nimmt, für die Dienstleistung
den Fahrer über Funk zu informieren, wenn jemand angerufen hat und dorthin zu fahren. Das heißt, die Taxifahrer stehen an ihren den ihnen bekannten Stationen oder fahren durch die Stadt und über Funk ist dann irgendwie
rufst du bei äh rufst du an, sagst hallo, ich bin äh,
in der und der Straße, ich brauche einen Wagen. So, die nehmen das über Anruf entgegen, dann funken die los und sagen hier in der Region ist was.
Da haben sie natürlich dann auch so halbwegs äh Innovationen gehabt, wie das das übern Digitalfunk äh funktioniert, wo dann irgendwie die Sachen nur noch aus deiner Umgebung angezeigt werden und so weiter,
Und für diese Dienstleistung zahlt der Taxifahrer einhundertfünfzig Euro ähm an jede dieser Rufagenturen. Das heißt, der muss schon mal an zwei zahlen.
Zweimal in dieselbe Firma.
Da sind letztendlich steckt der Gleiche dahinter. So, jetzt nagelt mich bitte nicht auf die auf die einzelnen Beträge fest. Vielleicht muss ja auch nur fünfundsiebzig pro,
Agentur bezahlen, aber das heißt, das war deren äh deren Geschäftsmodell, nämlich ein Gateke zu sein, zwischen dem Taxifahrer und seinen Kunden.
Und dann kam ähm dann kam mytexte und hat gesagt, wir machen eine App,
übrigens bescheuert finde, ich rufe immer noch die Vermittlungszentralen an, weil es viel einfacher ist, sich die Schuhe zu zu binden und äh dabei irgendwie kurz zu sagen, schick mal einen Wagen vorbei, als irgendwie an dieser Mytexy App da rumzuklicken und danach musste dann noch irgendwie sollst du den Fahrer bewerten und dann.
Piept dat da rum und dann soll's hier auf Google Maps angucken, wo der lang,
ich weiß, du bist ja ein digital Native, ich bin ja jemand, der einfach ein Taxi braucht, ähm.
Es gibt Fälle, also weiß nicht, ob wir jetzt so viel über den Alltag so unterhalten müssen, aber es gibt schon sehr viele Momente, wo so eine Taxizentrale echt saugt
betreten, wenn irgendwie äh Großveranstaltung ist, äh ruft mal irgendwo an und hofft mal, dass ihr mal wirklich mal ein Taxi ankommt, da stand ich schon.
Was ist denn, was ist denn mein Problem? Also Moment mal, der Regen regnet sowieso, ob ich mir das Telefon jetzt an Ohr halte oder in der Hand behalte, habe ich.
Ich bin irgendwo und will nach B und ich bin irgendwie draußen im Freien und nicht zu Hause bei mir. So und jetzt will ich irgendwie so schnell wie möglich weg und ich will das irgendwie auch halbwegs
timen können? Wann gehe ich jetzt hier wirklich irgendwie aus meinem Unterschlupf, den ich mir jetzt hier gerade gesucht habe, zur Straße, um wirklich dann das Taxi auch zu kriegen. Wenn ich jetzt bei einer Taxizentrale anrufe
ist sie erstmal besetzt. So, dann komme ich ey, das habe ich alles schon hunderttausend Mal gehabt. Dann.
Das war noch nie passiert.
Dir ist es noch nie passiert, dass die Taxizentrale ich äh bitte dich, also in Berlin habe ich da schon so oft gehabt.
Ein einziges Mal, aber okay, gut.
Irgendwie bestellt dir ein Taxi, ja, irgendwas, ja.
Love Parade, bestelle dir ein Taxi. Und da wird dann bei der Love-Rate funktioniert dein drei G noch mit der App oder was? Komm.
Nein, die ganze Stadt ist ja dann sozusagen am Bestellen, unabhängig davon, äh wo du bist, wenn du jetzt,
bestelle mir nicht ein Taxi auf die Love Prode, aber während einer solchen Großveranstaltung und
gibt's ja nun eh nie mehr, äh irgendeine andere große Veranstaltung. Davon haben wir ja nun wirklich eine Menge Marathon zum Beispiel, ist auch so ein so ein Moment, wo jetzt auch noch mit Absperrungen und wo kommt man denn hin? Und so weiter. Hast du so eine App?
Ja? Weißt du, ich habe jetzt direkt in diesem Moment wirklich auch ein Taxi zugeteilt bekommen und ich sehe auch sofort, wo's langfährt und ich weiß auch ganz genau, wenn's ankommt,
Ist egal, das ist, glaube ich, Bestandteil auch dieser ganzen äh Entwicklung, manche mögen das, manche nicht. Ich mag das. Und ich habe da auch einen ganz anderen Zugriff und vielleicht um da äh das kurz noch nachzuschieben, wo du jetzt sagst, so äh,
Geschäftsmodelle der Taxifahrer, es gibt da noch einen selteneren Fall, das sind halt die etablierten Fahrer, die eben auch schon so lange fahren und ähm sagen wir mal so eine eigene Marke aufgebaut haben, dass sie auch ihre eigenen,
Kunden haben, was weiß ich, Geschäftsleute regelmäßig fahren, beziehungsweise einfach als ausreichend äh vertrauenswürdig oder zuverlässig oder freundlich oder eine Summe von allem,
dass die quasi mit ihrem eigenen Handy auch schon ausreichend Aufträge reinkriegen, gibt's auch, ja?
Auch, ja, aber das ist ja nun wirklich kein äh kein, kein nennenswerter Anteil. Aber kommen wir mal, kommen wir mal dazu, was hat jetzt, wie hat Mytexy diesen äh Prozess,
Rationalisiert und und irgendwie weg automatisiert, ne? Das ist ja das das Schöne eigentlich. Die haben eine App,
Und die haben irgendwo einen Server. Und der Server, auf dem läuft ein bisschen Backend, ne? Da gehen irgendwie dann die Requests ein,
Ja, da steht dann, was weiß ich, eine GPS-Koordinate dran und dann fängt die äh fängt der Server an, die Taxi, die als Taxifahrer registrierten äh Nutzer
in deinem Umkreis zu informieren, ne, dann geht das so bling, bling, bling, bling, bling, macht ja den Kreis immer größer. Ähm alle paar Sekunden, bis dann irgendwann einer sagt, jo, möchte ich machen.
Mhm.
Und in dem Fall wird dann eine ähm Provision ähm fällig. Das heißt, der Taxifahrer bei myTaxi,
hat nicht mehr eine Flatrate, wo jemand irgendwie über Funk das rumschickt und der schnell drücken muss, sondern er zahlt pro Vermittlung,
Das ist natürlich schön, weil er unter Umständen,
Ähm weniger bezahlen muss, wenn er nicht, wenn er nicht ordentlich vermittelt bekommt oder wenn da irgendwie Fahrten drin sind, die für ihn jetzt nicht attraktiv sind, äh die er sich schnappt. Ähm gleichzeitig ist natürlich das dann wieder so eine,
Ähm,
ja dann auch eine Macht über diese Vermittlung, nämlich wem sagen sie Bescheid. Und das ist ja das, wo sie erst vor einiger Zeit dann dran angefangen haben zu spielen, dass sie gesagt haben, ja, liebe Taxisfahrer, uns ist irgendwie aufgefallen,
Dass einige von euch ja sogar bereits sind, siebzig Cent für die Vermittlung zu bezahlen, während andere lieber nur so dreißig zahlen wollen,
Könnt ihr machen.
Wer mehr zahlt, kriegt mehr Aufträge.
Wer mehr zahlt kriegt mehr, kriegt die Aufträge als Erstes.
Genau. Angebot und Nachfrage.
Relativ also das sind natürlich dann die immer als ekelhaft empfundenen ähm und äh Mechanismen des Marktes, die es in irgendwie auch gilt ähm,
in den Griff zu bekommen, ne? Ähm aber letztendlich, wenn dann myTexi irgendwann in der Position ist, der einzige äh oder die die eine sehr verbreitete Methode äh des,
Taxivermittlung zu sein, auf die sich ein, auf die sich Fahrer konzentrieren können, dann ziehen die natürlich die Preise an, ne? Und ähm dann haben sie ja noch dieses dieses,
Taxifahrer Bewertung und so da dran, das ist übrigens der einzige, also es gibt zwei valide Gründe, die ich höre von anderen, viel Taxifahrern, äh warum sie MyTexy nutzen?
Nummer eins, sie sehen wirklich die Karre anfahren, das heißt, sie können sich aussuchen, wann sie anfangen, die Treppe runterzugehen. Vor allem bei Regen, dass der das einvalider.
Kannst den auch anrufen.
Kannst den anrufen, ja, ist auch ein.
Kannst ja auch feiner aus äh einstellen zum Beispiel, wenn du irgendwie so spezielle Kindersitze und so weiter brauchst.
Kannst du am Telefon auch?
Mal ja, der praktisch nicht.
Der der zweite äh zentrale Punkt, den den ich höre, ist der Taxifahrer oder die Taxifahrerin, wissen, dass du am Ende diese Sterne da gibst.
Wie war der wie war der Fahrer? Äh oder wie war ihre Fahrt? Wie war ihr Erlebnis?
Wie war das Auto?
So und wie war das Auto? Kommen wir gleich noch zu. Ähm,
und das äh meinen einige der Menschen, mit denen ich mich darüber unterhalten habe, äh beobachten zu können, führt zu einem sehr viel freundlicheren Auftreten des Taxifahrers. Die sind nicht mehr so pampig zu dir.
Ja? Weil natürlich auch ihre Sternchen ein weiterer Faktor dafür sind, wie die App ähm,
welche Person die App entscheidet, äh zu dir zu schicken oder welchen Taxifahrer, der Server entscheidet, äh als erstes zu benachrichtigen. So und seit äh Mytaxi irgendwie da Daimler dann noch die ähm,
die Finger drin hat, ähm wurde mir jetzt berichtet, das musst du dann als Nutzer nochmal bestätigen, dass es da den.
Perifolt aktivierten. Ich will aber nur einen Mercedes-Knopf gibt. Das habe ich irgendwie auf Twitter gelesen, das weiß ich aber nicht, ob das stimmt.
Nö. Wenn ich ein Taxi bestelle, dass er sagt, äh ich will nur Mercedes.
Ja? Kannst du das irgendwie in den Suchpräferenzen einstellen.
Wenn wir neu, warte mal.
Aber das sind dann nämlich das sind dann natürlich auch noch ähm also kann sein, dass das irgendwie jemand war, der da äh philosophiert hat auf auf Twitter,
So und jetzt das heißt, die gehen die gehen hin zu einer Position. Einerseits die die Distanz zwischen den Kunden und den Dienstleistern ähm die gefühlte Distanz zu verkleinern.
Ja, also es gibt, es gibt die Option Mercedes-Benz-Taxi.
Ganz lustig, ne? Komisch, wie die wohl da reingeraten ist. Ähm wenn es jetzt so das Renault-Taxi oder ne, wenn ich jetzt gerne Toyota Hybrid fahren möchte?
Da gehört halt Benz.
Eben, ne? Da sieht man halt natürlich, wie wie's da äh wieder,
auch die die Kunden und deren Interessen zum Spielball der äh Konzerne werden. Ähm so und jetzt geht aber jemand hin und sagt, na ja,
Ist ja ganz schön, dass jemand hingeht und mit einer App äh den, den Markt der Taxifahrer aufrollt und sich da als äh Schmarotzer zwischen Kunden und Taxifahrer setzt,
ähm und Geld verdient. Das haben ja andere vorher auch schon immer so gemacht, eben jene Taxivermittlungszentralen, die die Taxifahrer haben richtig bluten lassen. Jetzt lässt sie halt diese App richtig bluten und nach ähm.
Marktliberalen Prinzipien kommen da ja sowieso nur gute und stabile Preise raus,
Aber das eigentliche, das eigentliche Markthindernis sind doch die festregulierten Taxipreise. Weil was der Kunde ja eigentlich möchte, ist, dass sich die ähm die sein, seine Chauffeure noch darum streiten, äh,
den Preis zu unterbieten, zu dem sie den Kunden von A nach B fahren dürfen mit einem Mercedes oder sonstigen.
Und das kann man ja sehr schön umgehen, indem man auf diesen ganzen Mist verzichtet, der den den Taximarkt reguliert.
Über äh die hohen TÜV-Auflagen, die sie haben über die äh die ähm,
verlangen äh Ausweise und und Lizenzen. Alles wird weg, wegrationalisiert, sodass Leute, die ein Auto haben, die App anmachen und sofort Fahraufträge bekommen können.
Uber nimmt eine Provision ähm und die Fahrer äh
im Zweifelsfall äh ihre äh Einnahmen da noch nicht mal beim Finanzamt an und können natürlich dann auch radikal äh Taxifahrer äh unterbieten. Und entsprechend hat dann auch eine
Taxi Zentrale, nämlich der Betreiber der App Taxi Deutschland, die also sich darauf spezialisiert haben, Taxifahrer zu melden gegen,
äh den Betrieb des Dienstes obergeklagt. Und jetzt ist natürlich interessant, mit welcher ähm.
Mit welcher Argumentation die gegen diesen Dienst ähm,
klagen konnten, denn die eigentliche Beförderungsdienstleistung erbringt ja jemand anders, nämlich der Nutzer von Uber.
Und das Landgericht Frankfurt hat also argumentiert über das.
Personenbeförderungsgesetz Paragraph sechsundvierzig Gelegenheitsverkehr und das dürfen also taxen.
Ausflugs und Ferienzielfahrten und Verkehr mit Mietwagen,
Nur betrieben werden mit Genehmigung. Und das Minimum dafür ist eben der äh Personenbeförderungsschein plus irgendwelche weiteren Auflagen. Und das heißt, wenn du darauf verzichtest.
Dann ist es ein Wettbewerbsverstoß. Und.
Vermittelt diese Wettbewerbsrechtsverletzungen.
Wenn du jetzt also den dem Täter sagst du, du hast gegen das Wettbewerbsrecht verstoßen, also du hast ein, du hast dich bei Uber angemeldet und eine Fahrt vorgenommen, obwohl du nicht im, obwohl du nicht die regulatorischen Auflagen erfüllst. Äh,
und der Teilnehmer von Uber, der hat die Prüfpflichten verletzt und dadurch einen Wettbewerbsverstoß billigend in Kauf genommen.
Also mit Teilnehmer meinst du jetzt jemand, der sich vermitteln lässt.
Ja, der wissentlich U-Bahn nutzt, obwohl ihm bekannt ist, er darf es nicht.
Nein, du redest so vom Fahrgast. Der der Fahrgast.
Du bist als du wirst als Fahrgast dazu verpflichtet zu schauen, wenn dich jemand wenn jemand eine Beförderungsdienstleistung an dir vornimmt, dass diese Person auch dazu berechtigt ist.
Und Uber macht genau das gezielt klar, die haben ja sogar ihren Leuten empfohlen, zu sagen, ey, ähm,
Gebt an.
Eure Abrechnung, dass ihr nur die die die Abnutzungs äh Kosten in Rechnung stellt und dass alles, was darüber hinausgeht, ein Trinkgeld ist.
Denn solange du nur die Abnutzungskosten in Rechnung stellst, kannst du das machen, siehe die Leute, die eben äh Mitfahrgelegenheit machen. Das war ja, das ist etwas, was in Ordnung ist, weil sie quasi nicht kommerziell,
und nicht eine Dienstleistung erbracht haben, sondern Carsharing, Carpulen betrieben haben, sich die Kosten geteilt haben.
Beruft sich oft auf auf die Situation von Mitfahrzentralen.
Und äh genau so bewerben sie auch das Modell, ja? Also dieser dieser Chef von Uber sagt ja so, wir führen hier einen Krieg
und das ist ähm der der Krieg quasi oder der Kampf zwischen einer freien Welt, in der Menschen teilen äh gegenüber und der Gegner ist der der hässliche, die hässliche Markt beherrschende Konzernstrukturtaxi.
So grob hatte das.
Sehr interessant, weil es gibt ja auch noch einen anderen Dienst, den wir gar nicht so erwähnt haben in dem Zusammenhang. Äh flink, sagt dir das was? F L, INC,
Ist ja im Prinzip auch so die vollautomatisierte äh Mitfahrzentrale.
Ach, du hattest, ja ja, ich erinnere mich.
Ja, wo du sozusagen als ähm ja Fahrer auch regelmäßiger Fahrer, also deine regelmäßigen Touren explizit äh bewerben
zu Integration in Navigationssystem Apps und so weiter
auch noch während einer Fahrt die Möglichkeit hast auf request anzugehen, also du bist was weiß ich unterwegs hier von Berlin nach
München und halbe Stunde bevor du an Nürnberg vorbeikommst, meint irgendjemand hier ich muss mal nach München, da fährt ja gerade einer würde ja passen, würdest du einen Umweg machen, dann kommt das Ding halt hoch und sagt, hier Umweg würde dich so und so viel kosten, so und so viel einbringen et cetera, frage ich mich, äh ob die dann äh in dem selben Maße nicht
ähm.
Ja, ich glaube.
Sozusagen also ob die selben Maße dagegen verstoßen.
Ich glaube, die die Argumentation ist schon ziemlich klar äh.
Wo man sagt, du bist jetzt ein kommerzieller Betreiber oder du äh verrichtest eine freundschaftliche ähm.
Genau, du fährst ja ohnehin schon, nimmst jemanden mit und der beteiligt sich an den Kosten, völlig in Ordnung. Aber wenn du ein, wenn du einen Dienstanbieter bist.
Er wird dich nur deshalb auf der Straße ist, um entsprechend vermittelt zu werden, dann fällt es halt anders an. Ja, ist ja richtig,
Gut, also das ist jetzt erstmal eine Entscheidung ähm jetzt haben wir mal wieder hier unseren Moment des Landgerichts Frankfurt hat das äh gemacht. Uber hat das jetzt erstmal ignoriert, obwohl da theoretisch ähm,
wie.
Enorme Strafen. Da waren irgendwie so so völlig utopische Beträge.
Aber nicht sofort losgehen, also man üblicherweise werden die erstmal in niedrigeren Maße gestellt und dann erst mit weiterem Verzug äh gesteigert, zumindest das.
Kann sein, aber in den, in den, in den in den äh Presseberichten war dann irgendwie so für jede einzelne Vermittlung könnte Uber jetzt ein Ordnungsgeld in Höhe von äh drei Lebensgehälter.
Ja genau, aber sie sagen, es ist immer noch billiger, diese Medien weite Aufmerksamkeit zu haben und sogar in Lokbuch ausführlich diskutiert zu werden und dadurch alle Leute dazu bringen, überhaupt erstmal über diesen Dienst nachzudenken. Ich meine, das ist genauso vorher war das ja schon in London, wo dann die Taxifahrer,
demonstriert haben, also gestreikt haben
ja? Und durch durch diesen Streik als Protest gegenüber den so dermaßen viele Kunden zugespült.
Nicht nur in London, das war in Deutschland genauso. Es war eine.
Ja, jetzt ist es hier auch so, ja.
So war das, ah okay.
In London äh der Fall, ja. Und äh jetzt haben wir halt einen ähnlichen Effekt, deswegen ziehen die auch ihre App nicht zurück, weil es jetzt sozusagen billiger ist,
das Geld in Gerichtsstrafzahlungen zu stecken als deutschlandweit zu plakatieren.
Also da ähm ist, glaube ich, der Punkt, dass sie wissen, dass die die vor Gericht nachgewiesen werden müsste, dass sie diese
also jede einzelne Vermittlung müsste ihnen nachgewiesen werden für dieses Ordnungsgeld. Und da setzen die einfach darauf, dass das nicht in in großem Maße geschieht. Aber klar, die haben auch eine Kampfkasse und die sind natürlich auch bereit, eventuell Strafen dafür zu zahlen, aber die Finanzierung ist
also die Strafe ist hoch genug, dass äh,
dass sie äh das nicht lange sinnvoll weiter betreiben könnten, wenn sie diesen Preis zahlen müssten. Aber.
Warum reden wir denn überhaupt dadrüber.
Genau, weil sich da jetzt wirklich, du hast ja gerade schon von der Disruption gesprochen, weil sich da ziemlich ein ziemlich radikaler Wandel,
andeutet in vielen Bereichen der die gesamte
Ökonomie betrifft. Und ich finde, während der Gedanke einerseits sehr ähm reizvoll ist, Dinge zu teilen und es auch sinnvoll ist, dass wir als Gesellschaft uns von irgendwie dieser ganzen Besitzerei mal irgendwann verabschieden und äh Anfang äh vorhandene Ressourcen effizient zu nutzen. Ja, überlegt mal, wie viel
wie viel Wertverlust wir irgendwie dadurch haben, dass dass Menschen versuchen, Dinge zu besitzen, ja, dass Fahrzeuge rumstehen, statt zu fahren, ja?
Ähm während wir gleichzeitig es hiermit mit ähm Unternehmen zu tun haben,
die eigentlich nur Macht äh Positionen,
ausnutzen, Vermittlungsentgelte äh kassieren. Äh und sich dadurch irgendwie füttern lassen. Das heißt, dieser äh,
coole sexy äh Share-Gedanke ähm der wird da in deren Geschäftsmodellen schon auf eine sehr schäbige Art und Weise,
ähm tja, ausgenutzt.
Und ähm es gab einen sehr schönen Artikel, den ich äh vor einigen vor einiger Zeit schon gelesen habe, vor argumentiert wurde, ey, dass wir so was haben wie Taxis,
dass die so reguliert sind, das hat auch Vorteile, denn dann kommt wenigstens ein Taxi bei Glatteis und fertig eine Minute nachm äh nach nach Mitternacht an an Neujahr ähm irgendwie drei Kilometer weiter.
Und das ist bei U-Bahn nämlich nicht so. Da kommt jemand, der ist äh notfalls bereit, äh die Oma die Treppe runterzutragen.
Auch wenn sie irgendwo auf dem Land wohnt,
wo eigentlich keiner Bock hat hinzufahren und die Fahrt vielleicht kommerziell unsinnig ist, ja? Das all das hast du ja dann nicht mehr, wenn wenn sage ich wenn diese Märkte vollständig entreguliert werden.
Insofern fand ich das sehr äh
sehr, sehr finde ich diese Debatte grade sehr interessant und habe mich jetzt bemüht, das auch mal alles so wiederzugeben, welche welche von welchen Effekten wir da eigentlich reden. Und ich bin ein äh Nutzer von Airbnb. Ich werde nächste Woche
wieder Airbnb sein und find das eigentlich sehr cool. Bin aber auch Nutzer von Couchsurfing.
Hm, Abgründe tun sich auf.
Da tun sich Abgründe auf Nutzer von Uber bin ich nicht äh und von Mytexy ja auch nicht. Aber ich.
Disclaimer, ich habe auch schon mal Airbnb äh in Anspruch genommen, aber ich habe noch nicht über äh Bienenwie etwas angeboten, ne. Ich meine, das hatten wir hier auch gerade im Viertel, ist das ja hier ein äh echtes Problem, das also wirklich so dermaßen viele Wohnungen ähm
sozusagen an Touristen äh untervermietet werden. Was ich deren,
Ja, also ich kenne auch Leute, die das in Anspruch genommen haben. Das ist natürlich total super, wenn du äh nach Berlin kommst und du hast so eine Wohnung, ist einfach ein ganz anderes äh Ding, ja? Und das irgendwie noch zu halbwegs bezahlbaren äh Preisen.
Was ja auch zum Beispiel dazu geführt hat, ähm dass in Städten wie New York ähm dieser dieser Dienst Airbnb
natürlich verboten ist, übrigens in Berlin auch, ne. Ist äh das das Vermieten deiner äh von Wohnraum über Airbnb nicht gestattet. Weil das äh als eine kommerzielle Nutzung,
ähm von äh Wohnraum, nicht gewerblichen Wohnraum in einem sehr stark regulierten Gewerbe, nämlich dem Hotel Gewerbe ist.
Ja, der Stausee Tim.
Sehe, aber es gibt ja hunderte von Angeboten in Berlin.
Ja und die haben alle ein äh Problem und diejenigen, die das äh da gibt's dann eine Regulation für und diejenigen, die das irgendwie äh kommerziell betreiben, die müssen dann eben äh das auch vor allem mal ähm,
Äh Finanz, Finanziell, dem Finanzamt gegenüber rechtfertigen?
Gut, das kann man ja machen.
Also ähm,
die wollen natürlich nicht an die Leute, die irgendwie sagen, ja gut, ich habe die Wohnung und ich mache nächste Woche äh fliege ich drei Wochen in Urlaub und es wäre super geil
wenn ein Teil dieses Urlaubs dadurch finanziert ist, dass irgendwie ein paar Leute mal 'ne Woche bei mir wohnen,
Aber sie wollen das Problem sind natürlich eben genau jene Leute, die diese Dienste dann eben professionalisieren, kommerzialisieren,
eben eine Wohnung anmieten und die grundsätzlich bei RNPNBNB Airbnb drin haben,
und und das quasi als als Hauptberuf machen,
Und das ist natürlich etwas, wo dann äh so bitter das ist auch äh von gesetzgeberischer Seite versucht wird, gegenzuregulieren, weil in der Wohnung könnten ja auch Menschen wohnen.
Dafür war sie immer da,
Jetzt habe ich sehr stark äh äh die Position gegen Ober und Airbnb äh eingenommen. Meine meine persönliche äh Meinung ist natürlich da sehr viel egoistischer. Bei der Nutzung dieser Dienste.
Irgendeinen Mittelweg muss ich finden lassen, weil nicht jede jede Nutzung jetzt generell äh hier zu verurteilen ist, ne. Also wir merken ja selber an unserem eigenen Bedarf, da gibt's sehr wohl eine Nachfrage, die wir für uns äh auch absolut
legitimieren können und kommerzielle Angebote, alles super, ja, aber warum nicht auch was Privates finden können, vermittelt über einen Dienst.
Den man ja sonst auch in Anspruch genommen hätte früher, ne. So ähm.
Du willst, du wirst langsam.
Muss äh genau, ich muss äh langsam zum Ende kommen, aber du hast noch einen kleinen äh Beitrag, oder?
Eigentlich zwei. Ähm.
Da machen wir, pass auf, da machen wir, machen wir noch ein, ein Thema, noch ganz kurz. Das, was, was diese Woche auch sehr äh große Wellen noch geschlagen hat oder in der vergangenen Woche war, dass ähm,
Tracking über Mobilfunknetze. Ja, das es also Anbieter gibt, die ähm,
es als Dienstleistung anbieten, dass du quasi herausfindest, wo ein äh Mobiltelefon beziehungsweise dessen Nutzer sich äh gerade auf der Welt befindet,
und äh das ist etwas, das seit einiger Zeit schon,
möglich ist, vorgestellt, boah, weiß ich nicht wie viel Jahren von äh Tobias Engel aufm Chaos Communication Congress. Ähm,
und über verschiedene Funktionen,
Protokolls funktioniert über das Mobilfunknetze miteinander untereinander sprechen. Das heißt, du hast irgendwie ein Mobilfunknetz und das muss ja irgendwie auch in den.
Mit den anderen Mobilfunknetzen seine Funktionen
seine Funktionalitäten abstimmen können. Und das äh funktioniert über das globale äh SS sieben Netzwerk Signing Signaling System seven. Äh ein relativ,
antikes Protokoll, was da zwischen den Mobilfunknetzen gesprochen wird. Und ich meine, dass ich in der Sendung mit Ulf auch schon mal erklärt habe, äh wie man den Befehl message nutzen kann,
um herauszufinden, wo sich ein anderer Nutzer befindet. Ähm das Ganze.
Geht aber noch mit einer ganzen Reihe anderer Befehle,
und ist ein eine relativ großes äh ein relativ großer Mess. Ich will das, weil wir jetzt ein bisschen zeitliche Beschränkungen haben, nur grob nochmal erklären, dass dieses,
Dass diese Funktionen des SS sieben halt teilweise zum Betrieb der Mobilfunknetze unerlässlich sind und das ist ähm.
Änderungen, Architektur und Design der Mobilfunknetze erfordert diese Trackingmöglichkeiten,
einzudämmen. Ist aber grundsätzlich nicht unmöglich, das ähm zu verhindern. Zum Beispiel bei diesem äh Befehl Sandrothing Info for Short Message, wo es eigentlich darum geht, dass man als Mobilfunknetz sagt, schau mal,
Liebes anderes Mobilfunknetz. Ich habe hier eine Kurznachricht, die würde ich gerne an deinen Nutzer zustellen,
Sag mir doch mal an welcher MSC der sich gerade befindet, dann spreche ich direkt mit diesem Teil des Mobilfunknetzes und sage dem eben, dass diese Nachricht zugestellt werden muss.
MSC, was MSC gesagt?
Ja, ja, du bist immer so ein Abkürzungserfrager, ne?
Äh ich meine, wenn ihr jetzt hier irgendwie auf einmal voll auf digital äh Technik einsteigst, wo wir uns eben gerade noch über Touristenwohnungen unterhalten haben.
Mobile Mobile Services switching Center. Das ist quasi eine ähm.
Vermittlungsstelle.
Die erste Ebene, die erste Ebene Vermittlungsstelle nach den Funkmasten. Also all mehrere Funkmasten hängen an einem MSC.
Das weiter machen.
OK und die MS in der MS die MSC quasi sagt an ihren ganzen Funkzellen hier,
die Nachricht äh für den Linus ist da und dann geht die durch die ganzen Funkzellen und wird dann von meinem Mobiltelefon empfangen. Ähm,
Wenn man jetzt diesen das Ausnutzen dieses Befehles,
verhindern möchte, dann muss ich also mein Mobilfunknetz so bauen, dass ich eine zentrale Stelle in meinem Perimeter habe, wo alle Nachrichten erstmal hingehen, dort gefiltert werden und dann weitergeleitet werden, sodass ich nach außen,
anderer Mobilfunknetze nicht mehr verrate, wo sich meine Nutzer in dem Netz gerade befinden.
Ja, also der ähm ich denke, da das Prinzip ist klar und ich bin mir relativ sicher, dass es in der Sendung mit Ulf auch nochmal ausführlicher erklärt habe. Und,
Das Problem geht's jetzt aber noch für für andere ähm für andere Befehle im SS sieben,
die ich jetzt im Detail nicht mehr erklären werde. Aber der entscheidende Punkt an der Stelle ist, dass dieses SS sieben vor vielen Jahren relativ offen gestaltet wurde, weil man davon ausgegangen ist, dass ich dann nur vertrauen,
vertrauenswürdige Entitäten drin befinden und ähm das ist eben bei weitem nicht mehr so.
Und da werden jetzt Mobilfunknetze ähm Änderungen vornehmen müssen.
Um diesen dieser Ausnutzung, die da seit Jahren schon stattfindet auch ähm.
Enrique vorstellen.
Ein Riegel vorzuschieben. Ich bin mir sehr sicher, dass wir da äh beim einunddreißig C3 nochmal sehr viel mehr zu hören werden,
oder vielleicht mache ich das auch nochmal in einer anderen Podcast-Episode. Es ist ja nochmal mehr,
zu SS sieben erzähle. Aber das es ist halt für jemanden, der sich da länger mit auseinandersetzt ein ein wiederkehrendes Thema,
Das SS sieben. Kommt alle paar Jahre mal wieder hoch.
Ich hatte auch ähm Tobias hier schon zweimal im CRE zu,
Gast CRE null vierzig, äh ging über digitale Telefonnetze und wenn ich mich richtig erinnere
war da auch SS sieben ein Thema. Es kann aber auch genauso in der zweiten Sendung gewesen sein zum Thema NextGeneration Networks CAE einhundertzehn, wo wir auf diesen IP-Wandel äh äh
angesprochen haben, ne, was jetzt gerade der Telekom ja diese Woche auch schon wieder auf die Füße gefallen ist durch diesen,
komplett Ausfall ihrer ja das war schon immer so unsere Vorhersage da auch nochmal gut nachzuhören,
hat's stattgefunden von zweitausendneun,
Tobias auf jeden Fall extremer Blicker was die Telefonwelt betrifft schon immer gewesen seit ich ihn kenn Mobiltelefonie hat mit der in und auswendig.
Spricht, der spricht in diesem Protokoll.
Sprich GSM auf jeden Fall.
Wäre eigentlich schön. Da müssen wir mal gucken, ob man da vielleicht zu dem SS sieben nochmal was macht. Aber ich hätte's gerne mehr behandelt, aber wir wollten's ja mit mit Uber äh auseinandersetzen. Was ich auch.
Ja, wir können ja vielleicht mal Tobias hier mal reinholen, vielleicht wäre das ja mal ein schöner Aspekt.
Ich habe heute Morgen noch mit ihm gechattet und hatte eigentlich überlegt, ob ich ihn noch frage, aber hab's dann irgendwie verballert.
Gut, letzter Punkt.
Ja, ein Urteil des oberer Landesgerichts Hamm aus Mai dieses Jahres ist jetzt rechtskräftig und dieses Urteil besagt, E-Books dürfen nicht weiter verkauft werden, Ende der Meldung.
Auch eine spannende Debatte natürlich, weil ähm das aus Verbraucher äh Schutzperspektive natürlich durchaus eine Rolle spielt, ob ich einen erworbenes Produkt tatsächlich erworben habe und damit den Besitz an diesem Produkt ähm,
erworben habe und damit natürlich dann auch über dieses Produkt über dieses Objekt nach meinen Wünschen verfügen kann.
Und wenn das nicht der Fall ist, dann ist es natürlich äh eine durchaus massive Einschränkung, ne, meiner äh meiner Rechte als Verbraucher und ich äh glaube, die Debatte, der wir uns als Gesellschaft in Zukunft bei
unehmender Digitalisierung der Produkte und Dienstleistungen äh stellen müssen, ist dann eben ähm,
Tja, die Frage, können wir E-Books und Apps verleihen? Können wir die vererben?
Können wir die weitergeben, können wir die teilen. Das sind alles Fragen des Urheberrechts, die äh nach wie vor irgendwie unbeantwortet sind. Auch im Hinblick auf die
Geschäftsmodelle Jena äh kommerziellen Identitäten, die uns diese Produkte dann eben,
zur Verfügung stellen und verkaufen. Und da gibt's also jetzt dieses Urteil, das sagt ein E-Book,
darfst du nicht weiter verkaufen und ein gebrauchtes Buch darfst du dann eben nach zwanzig Jahren in die Papiertonne werfen oder in den Hausflur stellen,
oder eben auch über Amazon weiterverkaufen.
Ja, ist sehr interessant, ne, also als ob man bei dem einen was anderes kaufen würde als bei dem anderen. Ja, also vielleicht dreht sich das ja sogar noch mal so rum, dass du Bücher irgendwann auch nicht mehr weitergeben darfst, weil du quasi durch den Kauf des gedruckten Werks auch nur eine Lizenz zum äh Lesen erworben hast.
Das ist echt interessant, also die da die diese gesamte Urheberrechts äh bezogene Industrie hat, für die war's ein großer Segen,
dass ihre,
Produkte an ein physikalisches Objekt gebunden waren, von dem sich so leicht keine gleichwertige Kopie erstellen lassen konnte. Das hat die wirklich über Jahrzehnte ähm sehr gut leben lassen.
Und jetzt ist das vorbei und da müsste es auch eine gesellschaftliche Herausforderung ähm damit irgendwie umzugehen,
wie wir eben unsere Kreativen in Zukunft entlohnen wollen und damit sind wir auch beim Ende der Sendung, denn wir als Kreative werden ja auch entlohnt zum wiederholten Male bin ich bin nicht entlohnt, belohnt,
Und ich bin zum wiederholten Male von äh Till,
Neuhaus belohnt worden, der äh mit seiner großzügigen Unterstützung ähm zu dieser Sendung in einem Maße beiträgt, das ihm gar nicht äh vielleicht gar nicht bekannt ist, weil solche Unterstützung natürlich ähm,
echt.
Emotionale Wärme im Körper verteilen, die die Motivation aufrecht erhält. Äh die Sendung hier zu machen und da freue ich mich immer sehr drüber.
Mensch Linus. Aber das Hemd bleibt an. Ja äh.
Handelte sich um einen Whisky, ja, also diese Wärme von innen, die spürt man dann auch körperlich.
Mhm. Hast du auch mal die Flatterklicks äh Zahlen angeguckt in der letzten Zeit.
Ja, Dicke. Kinn runter. Meine schon, deine ja, aber das geht ja alles.
Wie meine, die der Sendung.
Die der Meterebene, die in deinem Klingelbeutel landen.
Ja, ja, das zahlt deine Clubmate. Komm, wir hauen uns jetzt,
Nee, das hat auch einen Grund, weil äh viele wahrscheinlich äh Instagram verwenden, um diesen Podcast zu hören und auch freundlicherweise da dieses Feature aktiviert haben, dass man quasi alles, was man hört, automatisch flattert.
Das geht ja doch. Und ähm das trägt nicht nur dazu bei, dass diese Sendung äh mehr bedacht wird, sondern das ist natürlich auch alles andere, was noch so gehört wird,
Ebene hin, Meterebene her, ja, es gibt auch noch andere gute Podcasts und äh ich finde das gut
wenn das äh sich möglichst breitflächig äh verteilt und dadurch auch noch ganz andere äh Medienoutlets äh entstehen in der nahen Zukunft
die vielleicht äh nochmal ganz andere Aspekte beleuchten, für die wir keine Zeit, Lust oder Kompetenz haben und äh insofern,
Dank hier einfach generell mal an die gesamte Hörergemeinde, die einfach durch ihr grundlegende Unterstützung dieser Modelle einfach zumal äh Sachen hier in Bewegung hält und bringt.
Genau, noch müssen wir uns nicht von Uber oder Airbnb vermitteln lassen.
Oh, ich brauche jetzt mal dringend einen Podcaster.
Aber noch ganz, noch eine ein Gedanke, der mir gerade kam, ne?
Zum Sex in ist leider und so.
Nimmt natürlich auch eine Provision für für ihr für ihren Dienst da. Der ist irgendwie die Provision ist sehr gering.
Aber natürlich auch noch mal geringer sein, wenn man äh aber wie dem auch sei, neben einer Provision. Was sie aber nicht machen, ist, dass sie sich in eine Position bringen. Und ich glaube, das unterscheidet äh so ein bisschen,
den Guten.
Dienst, der ihn wieder scheren kommerzialisiert, weil nichts anderes machen sie, sie Micropayment, ja, sie sie verdienen an.
Dingen mit, zu denen sie nicht beigetragen haben, ja? Ähm aber sowas wie Uber.
Aber sie tragen dadurch bei, ja.
Genau, sie tragen aber sie tragen überhaupt dadurch sie tragen irgendwie bei, ne? Und äh das da sehe ich irgendwie einen Unterschied zu Dienstanbietern wie Uber, Mytexi, Airbnb. Ähm die,
da auf eine etwas schäbigere äh Weise an diesen Marken partizipieren. Gleichzeitig ist aber dieser dieser Übergang sehr, sehr fließend und ich glaube, dass das eine sehr interessante ähm,
Herausforderung und Debatte in den nächsten Jahren sein wird, weil,
Insgesamt für eine Gesellschaft natürlich die Rationalisierung der äh Ressourcennutzung,
Fahrzeuge, ähm ich meine, Fahrzeug wird produziert, der Energieaufwand, ja. Die Kosten, dann steht das Scheißding monatelang da rum und nimmt anderen den Platz weg, ne. Ähm.
Das wird alles noch eine Rationalisierung erfahren
die Menschheit insgesamt weiterbringen wird. Aber das Schöne wäre halt, wenn der die Dividende dieser Rationalisierung dann nicht äh in in irgendwelchen Luxusjachten von irgendwelchen Silicon Valley Arschlöchern,
landen würde, sondern halt auch äh eine Dividende wäre, die der Gesellschaft dann am Ende zugute kommt.
Ja schön wär's. Auch der,
Tschüss.
Tschau, tschau.